हेलो
एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड इवनिंग
टू
ऑल एंड सबसे पहले मुझे यह बताइए कि सबको
मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है या नहीं दे रही
आई एम
ऑडिबल प्लीज चैट में यस या नो बता दीजिए
ताकि पता चल जाएगा मुझे
एवरीवन आई एम ऑडिबल और
नॉट सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही नहीं दे
रही बताइए
ओके मान सिंह थैंक यू एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग
मुझे लगा कि मेरी आवाज आप लोगों तक पहुंच
ही नहीं रही और
मैं क्योंकि दे आर ओनली 10 स्टूडेंट थोड़ा
दो मिनट के लिए वेट करते हैं और आई एम
सॉरी कि मैंने कल सेशन नहीं लिया बिकॉज कल
कल नहीं उससे पहले मैंने आपको प्रॉमिस
किया था बट बिकॉज ऑफ
क्रिकेट मैच मैं तो नहीं देखता बट आप लोग
देखते होंगे इसलिए क्लास जानबूझ कर नहीं
लिया ताकि आप लोग क्रिकेट देखने में बिजी
होंगे और आप लोग नहीं आ पाओगे इसलिए हमने
सेशन को पोस्टपोन कर दिया था अदर वाइज हम
जिस दिन मैथ था उस दिन हम देखने वाले थे
ओके तो प्लीज एक बार कंफर्म कर दीजिए सबको
आवाज पहुंच रही है नहीं पहुंच रही क्योंकि
जब मैंने पूछा
दैट टाइम दे आर 13 स्टूडेंट बट ओनली वन
स्टूडेंट रिप्लाई कि यस ऑडिबल और काफी
टाइम बाद
तो ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू मनीष कश्यप शायद
पहली बार क्लास में आ रहे हो क्या मनीष
कश्यप
यस क्योंकि पहली बार नाम सुना है तो आपकी
फर्स्ट क्लास
है
ओके तो सचिन भट्ट करियर गार्डेंस के लिए
के लिए मैं मुझे मैसेज आया और फॉर्म फिल
किया बट कॉल नहीं आया किसी का हमें किया
था
क्या यह हमसे रिलेटेड बात कर रहे हो
क्या तोके हो सकता है क्योंकि जो नितेश सर
थे हमारे जो सीईओ है तो वह थोड़े से बिजी
थे वो आउटसाइड स्टेशन थे अवेलेबल नहीं थे
और हम थोड़े से प्रोजेक्ट पर काम कर रहे
हैं बिजी है थोड़ा ट हो सकता है थोड़ा
डिले हुआ होगा तो जल्दी आपके पास कॉल आ
जाएगा उसकी चिंता मत कीजिए आपको डरने की
जरूरत नहीं है और अभी क्लास में कोई ना
कोई हमारा टीम
मेंबर्स इस क्यूरी को ले लेगा आपकी कररी
देख लेगा और जल्दी आपके पास कॉल आ जाएगा
मान सिंह का सवाल है सर क्या हमें जरूरी
है कि वनटी ढूंढ के दे के ही देनी है अगर
हम एज ए पन टेस्टर जवाइन करते हैं कोई
कंपनी में देखिए कंपनी में ऑफेंसिव टीम और
डिफेंसिव टीम दोनों ही होने जरूरी होती है
लेकिन क कुछ छोटी कंपनियां क्या करती हैं
कि जो ऑफेंसिव टीम है कई बार उन्हीं को ही
डिफेंसिव वाले भी टास्क प्रोवाइड कर देते
हैं अदर वाइज क्या करते हैं वे थर्ड
पार्टी हायर करते हैं कि ऑफेंसिव के लिए
खुद की टीम होगी और डिफेंसिव के लिए किसी
थर्ड पार्टी कंपनी को क्या कर देंगे अपनी
उनकी सर्विसेस लेंगे तो उसमें होता क्या
है कि आप ऑफेंसिव में आप हमेशा क्या करोगे
उस नेटवर्क की टेस्टिंग करते हो बिल्कुल
जरूरी नहीं क्योंकि आज किसी किसी कंपनी ने
अपने लिए एज ए पेंटेस्टर हायर कर दिया तो
आपकी जिम्मेदारी यह बनती है क्योंकि आप
क्या करोगे कि एक तरीका होता है कि कंपनी
के अंदर एक पॉलिसी बना के रखोगे कि मुझे
मंथली बेस प ऑडिट करना है या तीन मंथ में
छ महीने में या एक साल में ये ये इतना डीप
ऑडिट करूंगा मैं अपने सिस्टम्स का
सिस्टम्स की टेस्टिंग करूंगा कौन सी अपनी
पेन टेस्टिंग करूंगा तो ये चीज अपनी
पॉलिसी में आप बना के दोगे आपके जो
अथॉरिटीज हैं आपकी कंपनी अथॉरिटी है आप
कंपनी के जो चेयरमैन है या कंपनी की जो
एचआर या अथॉरिटीज हैं वह उस आपको उस
पॉलिसी पर एग्री करेंगे पॉलिसी पर एग्री
करने के बाद आपको यह भी बताया जाएगा आप
क्या-क्या कर सकते हो क्याक नहीं कर सकते
आप किसी कंपनी आप खुद ही उसी कंपनी के लिए
पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहे हो तो आपका काम क्या
है कि आप उस उस नेटवर्क के अंदर है तो
आपको बताना है कि अपनी रिपोर्ट में कि
मैंने ये पेन टेस्टिंग के ये स्टेप टेस्ट
किए है मुझे यहां पर शक है कि वलने बिलिटी
नहीं लेगी लेकिन मुझे शक है कि हां से
हमारा वीक पॉइंट हो सकता है तो ये रिपोर्ट
आप बना के दोगे तो उसके हिसाब से क्या
होगा आप फिर सजेशन भी दोगे कि आपने वीक
पॉइंट तो बता दिया फिर आपको यह भी बताना
होगा अपने बॉस को अपने सुपरवाइजर को कि सर
ये वीक पॉइंट है लेकिन इसका सोल्यूशन ये
है तो हम इसके लिए ये अप्लाई सॉल्यूशन
अप्लाई कर सकते हैं तो ये चीज जब आप
बताओगे या आप जो थर्ड पार्टी सर्विसेस ले
रहे होगे आप डिफेंसिव साइड से जो सोक
एनालिस टीम हो जब आपस में मीटिंग करोगे
आपने पन टेस्टिंग करके रिपोर्ट दे दी और
रिपोर्ट में उन्होंने उनको रिपोर्ट मिल गई
तो उसके बेस पर क्या होगी आपकी रिपोर्ट के
बेस पर क्या होगा कि जो शोक एनालिस्ट टीम
है या जो डिफेंसिव साइड टीम है या आप ही
वो काम देख रहे होगे आप ही की रिपोर्ट पर
क्या होगा एक एक और पॉलिसी एक और एसओ पी
जिसको बोल सकते हैं स्टैंडिंग टंग
प्रोसीजर्स होते हैं और गाइडलाइंस है जो
बनाई जाएंगी और उसके लिए फिर हायर अथॉरिटी
डिसाइड करेगी कि अभी इसके लिए हमें
सिक्योरिटी सोल्यूशन अप्लाई करना है या
नहीं करना है या उसके लिए हमें इसको कैसे
अवॉइड कर सकता हूं तो पेन टेस्टिंग में
एक्चुअल में यह होता है
का केस अलग है कि बग बाउटी में क्या कि
कंपनी किसी को हायर नहीं कर रही सिंपली
अपने डोमेन अपनी कंपनी को रजिस्टर करवा
दिया बग बांटी प्लेटफार्म में और दे लॉट
ऑफ पन टेस्टर्स व पन टेस्टिंग करते हैं और
उस परे रिपोर्ट करते हैं बट एज पन टेस्टर
आप किसी कंपनी में जवाइन करते हो तो आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी अलग होती है आपके वर्किंग
कल्चर अलग होता है जो मैंने बताया इस
तरीके से होता है तो आई थिंक की मान सिंह
शर्मा आपको समझ में आ गया होगा कि जो मैं
आपको बताने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं कि उसका
क्या मतलब है
समझ में आ गया मान
सिंह ओके तो चलो सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं
तो प्लीज कोई भी मुझे बताएगा कि जो ओल्ड
स्टूडेंट है जिसने हमारी लास्ट क्लास
अटेंड की है कि लास्ट सेशन में हमने क्या
पढ़ा डे 31 और डे 32 में हमने क्या कि खास
कर के डे 32 में हमने क्या डिस्कस किया
है अगर किसी का कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे अभी
बताइए कि डे 32 में किसी का कोई सवाल था
जो मुझे आपको आंसर करना होगा या फिर मेरा
सवाल यह है कि एक ब्रीफ समरी प्रोवाइड
कीजिए कि आपने क्या सीखा था डे 32 में जो
लास्ट क्लास थी कि मैंने आपको क्या पढ़ाया
था या क्या हमने डिस्कस किया था जल्दी से
बताइए
यश मान सिंह आईपीसी के बारे में पढ़ा था
और कुछ स्पेशल चीज स्टार्ट की थी आईपीसी
किसका पार्ट है बताइए जो आईपीसी है इंटर
प्रोसेस कम्युनिकेशन है वह किसका पार्ट
है बताइए
बताइए हां हां आगे
वेरी गुड मनीष तो आगे मुझे अभी मैं आपसे
पूछ रहा हूं कि आईपीसी तो आपने पढ़ा था बट
आईपीसी किसका पार्ट है कौन मेक शोर करता
है आईपीसी की जो टर्मिनोलॉजी कहां से आई
मतलब किस को किसी चीज के लिए तो बनाई गई
होगी
ना बताइए बताइए अच्छा
रहेगा नहीं आरपीसी विंडो सॉकेट इ द पार्ट
ऑफ आईपीसी आईपीसी को एक्सप्लेन करने का
मेरा तरीका था बट मैं आपसे य जानना चाहता
जो आईपीसी जो शब्द आया है जो एक
टर्मिनोलॉजी है एक टेक्निक है यह कहां से
आई है या किसकी वजह से आई है क्यों जरूरत
पड़ी
बताइए आपको पता
है प्लीज आंसर क्योंकि टॉपिक कंटिन्यू
करना है काफी इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन है आपको
कुछ और भी नई चीजें आज सीखने को मिलेंगी
जो शायद आपने आपको नहीं पता
होगा बताइए किसी को नहीं पता मान सिंह आप
डेली क्लास में आते हो और जगतगुरु आप भी
क्लास में आते हो और भी स्टूडेंट्स जो
डेली बेसिस पर क्लास अटेंड करते हैं तो
उनसे तो यह एक्सपेक्टेशन नहीं
थी
बताइए देखिए ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करेंगे क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं फिर
टॉपिक कंटिन्यू करना है दैट इज व्हाई आई
एम
आस्किंग सवाल यह है कि लास्ट क्लास में जो
डे 32 में मैंने आपको क्या पढ़ाया था एक
ब्रीफ सराइज प्रोवाइड
कीजिए नहीं नहीं मैंने एक चीज बताइए मैंने
सबसे पहले क्या बताया था कि ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम में जब आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की
हिस्ट्री स्टार्ट की थी हिस्ट्री स्टार्ट
के टाइम पर मैंने क्या बताया था कि पहले
जो प्रॉब्लम थी पहले जो प्रॉब्लम थी वो थी
कि जो आपकी एप्लीकेशन थी वोटिंग सिस्टम को
कर देती थी देन उसके बाद जो एप्लीकेशन
एप्लीकेशन को क्रैश कर देती थी अनस्टेबल
एप्लीकेशन लेकिन जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का
कोड था वो सेपरेट कर दिया गया था
आइसोलेटेड कर दिया गया था लेकिन बाद में
इस प्रॉब्लम को भी सॉल्व कर दिया गया कि
एक एप्लीकेशन दूसरे एप्लीकेशन के को
डिस्टर्ब नहीं कर सकती क्योंकि सारी
एप्लीकेशन सारे कोड आइसोलेटेड रहेंगे तो
उस केस में एक टम जनरेट की गई थी एक टर्म
आई थी प्रोसेस सबको पता है प्रोसेस से
रिलेटेड यस मनीष कश्यप सही एक प्रोसेस टम
का नाम सुना था तो प्रोसेस क्या है
प्रोसेस क्या है बताइए मैंने आपको बताया
था ना कि प्रोसेस क्या है
बताइए प्रोसेस क्या होती है
बताइए जल्दी से आंसर कीजिए सबको पता है एक
छोटा सा शब्द है जो आपको यूज करना है
किसी को नहीं
पता प्रोसेस क्या
है देखिए मैंने बताया था प्रोसेस एक
विजुअल कंटेनर है ठीक है जिस के अंदर आपके
एप्लीकेशंस के कोड रन करते हैं जो और कोड
एप्लीकेशंस को रन करने के लिए प्रोसेस के
अंदर एप्लीकेशंस को नहीं गलत है जगतगुरु
जी प्रोसेस एक वर्चुअल कंटेनर है उस
कंटेनर के अंदर आपकी एप्लीकेशंस रन करती
हैं उनको रन करने के लिए मेमोरी की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है सिक्योरिटी की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है थ्रेड्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है और आईपीसी की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है और आईपीसी आपके वो
सेट ऑफ रूल्स होते हैं जिनके थ्रू एक एक
प्रोसेस दूसरे प्रोसेस के साथ क्या कर स
है कम्युनिकेट कर सकती है विद इन द सेम
सेम मशीन या विद इन द सेम नेटवर्क या
आउटसाइड द नेटवर्क यह चीज मैंने आपको बताई
थी और आपको याद होनी चाहिए यह गलत बात
है इसका मतलब आप पढ़ाई पर ध्यान नहीं दे
रहे इसका मतलब है कि आप नहीं पढ़ रहे आप
रिवीजन नहीं कर रहे जस्ट सिंपली आप एक
क्लास को देख रहे हो उसके बाद उसको समझने
की कोशिश नहीं कर रहे क्योंकि आप सीरियस
नहीं हो अब
सच मैं बता रहा हूं सीरियस होने की जरूरत
है क्योंकि जो मैं आपको पढ़ा रहा हूं यह
काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
है मैं आपको आपका टाइम वेस्ट बिल्कुल नहीं
करूंगा फ्री है तो इसका मतलब मैं कुछ भी
नहीं पढ़ाऊंगा
मेरे लिए पेड और फ्री दोनों ही मायने रखते
हैं क्योंकि मैं अपनी मर्जी से पढ़ाता हूं
आपका सिलेबस डिफाइंड कुछ रहता है बट मैं
आप अपने इंटरेस्ट पे आप आप लोगों का
इंटरेस्ट देख के मैं चाहता हूं कि आप लोग
कुछ सीखो दैट इज व्हाई एम टेलिंग एवरीथिंग
इन वेरी डेप्थ ओके तो अभी हम बात करने
वाले हैं कंटीन्यूअसली कि प्रोसेस क्या
होती
है प्रोसेस क्या होती है मैं आप बता चुका
हूं ओके और एक वर्चुअल कंटेनर है उसके
अंदर एप्लीकेशंस रन होती है और
देन एप्लीकेशंस को रन करने के लिए मेमोरी
सिक्योरिटी आईपीसी और थ्रेड की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है चलो अभी हम बात करते
हैं कि जो एप्लीकेशंस है एक ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर जो एप्लीकेशंस रन करती है
आपकी वो कैसे रन करती है उस वो कैसे काम
करती है उसके बारे में बात करने वाले हैं
तो अभी हम सबसे पहले हम बात करेंगे कि
जैसा मैंने आपको बताया था फॉर एग्जांपल
अभी हमारे पास एक प्रोसेस है फॉर एग्जांपल
एक हमारे पास एक एप्लीकेशंस है एक
प्रोग्राम है जो आपकी हार्ड डिस्क आपकी
एसएसडी या आपकी मशीन के अंदर अवेलेबल है
फॉर एग्जांपल उसका नाम है माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
विंडो उसका नाम क्या है माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
विंडो और जैसे ही आप उस पर डबल क्लिक करते
हो तो आपकी प्रोसेस क्रिएट हो जाती है तो
अभी यहां पर मैं आपको क्या बताने वाला हूं
देयर इज ए सिंगल फाइल रिस्पांसिबल फॉर रन
ए प्रोसेस एंड दैट सिंगल फाइल इज
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर क्रिएटिंग दिस विचल
कंटेनर जैसे ही आप डबल क्लिक करते हो यहां
पर एक एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल होती है किसी भी
एप्लीकेशंस के अंदर जैसे ही आप उस
एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल के ऊपर क्लिक करते हो
तो वह जो सिंगल फाइल है वो सिंगल फाइल
आपकी प्रोसेस को क्रिएट करती है और वही
फाइल रिस्पांसिबल होती है उस वर्चुअल
कंटेनर को क्रिएट कंटेनर को क्रिएट करने
के लिए मल्टीपल फाइल की रिक्वायरमेंट होती
है नहीं एक सिंगल फाइल ही रिस्पांसिबल
होती है किसी भी प्रोसेस को क्रिएट करने
के लिए और उस वर्चुअल कंटेनर को क्रिएट
करने के लिए फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे ही
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वड इज यूज्ड बाय एवरीवन सबको
पता है द प्रोसेस ऑफ माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वड इज
रन बाय ए सिंगल फाइल कॉल्ड विव . जो भी
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वड आप यूज करते हो उसकी एक
एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल होती है winword.exe
नाम की फाइल होती है जैसे आप
microsoft.in क्रिएट करती है दिस फाइल इज
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर क्रिएटिंग द विजुलाइज
कंटेनर इट सेट अप ए मेमोरी एंड सिक्योरिटी
इट पुलस द मेनी मेनी अदर फाइल्स इनसाइड द
विजुलाइज कंटेनर अब यह क्या करती है एक
विजुलाइज कंटेनर क्रिएट किया उस उसके उसके
उसके अकॉर्डिंग मेमोरी प्रोवाइड करती है
सिक्योरिटी मेक श्योर करती है देन साथ के
साथ क्या होता है कि इस एप्लीकेशंस को रन
करने के लिए इस प्रोसेस को रन करने के लिए
या जो इसके अंदर जो कोड रन करेगा उसकी जो
डिपेंडेंसीज है उसको काम करने के लिए जिन
जिन फाइल्स की रिक्वायरमेंट है या जिन जिन
अदर लाइब्रेरीज की रिक्वायरमेंट है या अदर
जो डिपेंडेंसीज है उनकी रिक्वायरमेंट है
उनको फुलफिल यही फाइल करती है जो एक सिंगल
फाइल है दैट फाइल इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
मेंटे निंग द प्रोसेस मॉनिटरिंग द प्रोसेस
एंड टरिंग डाउन दैट प्रोसेस वन इट र यही
फाइल एक प्रोसेस को क्रिएट करती है एक
प्रोसेस को मेंटेन करती है एक प्रोसेस को
मॉनिटर करती है और साथ की साथ प्रोसेस को
टर्मिनेट भी करती है जब उसकी प्रोसेस उसका
काम कंप्लीट हो जाता है जब जो काम था आपके
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड का जैसे आप उसको क्लोज
करते हो तो उसके के अगेंस्ट भी एक टरिंग
ड्राइंग प्रोसेस होती है टर्मिनेशन
प्रोसेस होती है उसको भी फॉलो किया जाता
है इसको क्लोज करने से पहले क्या-क्या
चीजें शर करनी है तो यह सारे काम यही
सिंगल फाइल करती है ओके यहां तक सबको
क्लियर
है यह चीज शायद सबको पता है
ओके
बताइए नेक्स्ट अभी होता क्या है जैसे ही
आपने विन वड्स पर क्लिक किया आपकी प्रोसेस
स्टार्ट होगी और कई बार आप एज ए
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर आप क्या करते हो
कि उस प्रोसेस को राइट क्लिक करते हो
टास्क मैनेजर पर जाते हो और जैसे ही आप
टास्क मैनेजर पर जाते हो और राइट क्लिक
किया और उस प्रोसेस को क्या कर देते हो
एंड कर देते हो फोर्सफुली एंड कर देते हो
लेकिन यहां पर एक चीज ध्यान रखना जब आप
ऐसा करते हो तो क्या होता है इवन इफ आई एज
एन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर टेल ए प्रोसेस स्टॉप
एंड स्टॉप दैट दैट डज नॉट मीन इट इज गोइंग
टू डू व्हाट यू से आपने एज ए एडमिन आप
बोलो कि मैं एडमिन हूं और मैंने बोला कि
हां इस प्रोसेस को फोर्सफुली क्लोज कीजिए
इसका मतलब नहीं कि डायरेक्टली आपने क्लोज
करने के लिए बोला प्रोसेस को क्लोज कर
दिया ऐसा नहीं होता इट विल इनिशिएटिव
फुली क्लोज करोगे यह अपने जो टरिंग डाउन
प्रोसेस होती है जो उसकी किलिंग प्रोसेस
है उसको इनिशिएटिव
नहीं करेगी अपनी जो इनिशिएटिव
को कैसे टर्मिनेट करना है उसको इनिशिएटिव
किया और आपके कुछ सेकंड के बाद वो प्रोसेस
क्लोज हो जाती है वो कैसे हो जाती है
डायरेक्टली क्लोज नहीं होती वो अपना
प्रोसेस फुलफिल करती है जो उसको इनिशिएटिव
द प्रोसेस जो जो चीजें उसको क्लोज करनी है
या डाटा सेव करना जो भी कुछ करना है वो
करती है जो उसके कोड में डिफाइन किया गया
है ओके ऐसा नहीं है कि आप
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स हो और उसको एक ऑर्डर पास
करते हो और वह आपको फॉलो करेगा नहीं उसके
पास एक प्रोसेस है क्रिएट करने के भी उसके
पास एक प्रोसेस फॉलो करती है मेंटेन
टर्मिनेशन सब कुछ एक अरेंज वे में किया
जाता है वह सारे काम यह फॉलो करता है ओके
यह प्रोग्राम
नेक्स्ट तो अभी सम सराइज कर देता हूं ए
फाइल इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर स्टार्टिंग एंड
मेंटे निंग द प्रोसेस वन और मोर थ्रेड्स
रनिंग इन द प्रोसेस ओके इट फुलफिल्स देर
मेमोरी रिक्वायरमेंट्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
रिसोर्सेस दैट आर एलोकेट टू द प्रोसेस सच
एज हैंडल्स डीएलएस डेटा सोर्सेस
सिक्योरिटी
एटिबल ओनर एंड द प्रोसेस सेट ऑफ द आपको
समझ में नहीं आया होगा बेसिकली मैं आपको
समझाने की यह कोशिश कर रहा हूं कि एक
सिंगल फाइल जो एक सिंगल फाइल होती है किसी
भी प्रोसेस को स्टार्ट करने के लिए मेंटेन
करने के लिए उसके अंदर थ्रेड्स को रन करने
के लिए मल्टीपल थ्रेड्स को रन करने के लिए
और उसकी जो मेमोरी की रिक्वायरमेंट है
उसको फुलफिल भी उसकी फुलफिलमेंट भी वही
प्रोसे वही फाइल करती है उसके उस प्रोसेस
को रन करने के उसके अंदर एप्लीकेशंस है उस
कोड को रन करने के लिए जिन जिन डेटा
सोर्सेस की रिक्वायरमेंट है चाहे व
हैंडल्स हैं चाहे वो डीएलएस हैं या जो भी
डाटा सोर्सेस हैं इनपुट आउटपुट डिवाइस
सारी फुलफिल वही फाइल करती है साथ के साथ
उसकी सिक्योरिटी भी मेंटेन करती है कि
इसके ऊपर इस प्रोसेस को स्टार्ट करने के
लिए किसकी परमिशन है किसको परमिशन नहीं है
और ये प्रोसेस क्या कर सकती है क्या नहीं
कर सकती किसके साथ इंटरेक्ट कर सकती है
किसके साथ इंटरेक्ट नहीं कर सकती तो मतलब
उसके पास जो परमिशन डिफाइंड है उसकी भी
मैच्योरिटी कौन करती है यह सिंगल फाइल
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है यह सिंगल फाइल ही करती
है तो अभी नेक्स्ट
चले अभी नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट चले
ओके अभी फॉर एग्जांपल आप राइट क्लिक करोगे
और आपने क्या किया यह मेरी मशीन का
स्क्रीनशॉट है राइट क्लिक किया आपने दिस
पीसी और गो टू सिस्टम 32 और आपने यहां पर
क्या किया स्टार डीएलएल अभी यह जितनी भी
फाइल्स आपको देखने को मिल रही है यहां पर
आप कितनी फाइल्स है आपकी मशीन के
अकॉर्डिंग रहती है मेरे में मशीन में क्या
है
7377 फाइल्स है यही आपका पूरा पूरा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है यही आपका पूरा का पूरा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है ओके जितने भी
एप्लीकेशन डेवलपर्स हैं टर्न्स ऑफ डीएलएस
का यूज करते हैं चाहे वो विंडोज हो चाहे
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हो कुछ भी हो सभी इ
इन्हीं डीएलएस का यूज करते हैं और एक साथ
पैरेलली यूज करते हैं कैसे करते हैं इतना
स्मूथली बनाया गया है यह भी मैं आपको
बताऊंगा और इन अपकमिंग क्लासेस में हम
डीलर्स के बारे में काफी डिटेल्स में
पढ़ेंगे मैं मैं आपको बता रहा हूं कि अगर
पूरा पूरा ऑपरेटिंग से सिस्टम देखना है कि
कहां पर है तो आप यह देख सकते हो सिस्टम
32 के अंदर स्टार डीएल करो स्टार डीएलएल
करोगे तो ये सारी की सारी आपकी डीएलएल
फाइल्स है आपकी मशीन के मेरी मशीन के अंदर
7377 डीएलएल फाइल्स अवेलेबल है और डीएलएस
काफी इंपोर्टेंट है लाइब्रेरी फाइल्स है
किसी भी एप्लीकेशंस को रन करने के लिए
नेक्स्ट अभी आपने कभी भी राइट क्लिक करोगे
और टास्क मैनेजर पर करके देखोगे तो आप देख
पा रहे हो कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन है
कि मेरी मशीन में आपको देख पा रहे हो 5 पर
यूटिलाइजेशन स्पीड थ्रेड्स
हैंडल्स प्रोसेसेस 274 प्रोसेसेस
देखिए वी हैव 270 प्रोसेसेस रनिंग इन टू
आवर मशीन एंड प्रोबेबली 5000 थ्रेड्स एंड
थाउजेंड्स ऑफ
डीएलएस एक्टिवली रनिंग राइट नाउ
देख पा रहे हो मैं आपको दिखा दूंगा कि 270
प्रोसेसेस रनिंग है 5000 के करीब थ्रेड्स
हैं थ्रेड्स आपके एक्चुअल कोड्स होते हैं
जो रन करते हैं और डीएलएस की तो काउंटिंग
नहीं है दे आर थाउजेंड्स ऑफ डीएलएस जो
एक्टिवली रन कर रहे हैं एक साथ और जितने
भी डीएलएस है ऑल सेम डीएलएस आर बीइंग
यूज्ड बाय द 270 प्रोसेस एट द सेम टाइम
अभी 270 प्रोसेसेस एक साथ रन कर रही हैं
इसका मतलब सारे के सारे जो डीएलए कॉमन जो
सेम डीएलएस है और सभी के द्वारा यूज किए
जा रहे हैं तो सोचने की बात है कि
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ने उसको कैसे डिजाइन किया
होगा इतना स्मूथली कि
7377 डीएलएल है और एक बार में आपको 270
प्रोसेसर रनिंग है इतने नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स
हैं और सभी की रिक्वायरमेंट उन्हीं डीएल
7377 डीएलएल से फुलफिल हो रही है तो सोच
के देखिए कि माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ने कितना
स्मूथली डिजाइन किया है कि सेम डीएलएल का
यूज करके सेम एप्लीकेशंस सेम डीएलएस का
मल्टीपल एप्लीकेशन सेम डीएलएल का यूज यूज
कर पा रही है एक साथ और कोई भी कोई
प्रॉब्लम आपको देखने को नहीं मिल फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर आपकी कम ब्राउजर्स है जिस
डीएलएल को कम ब्राउजर यूज कर रहा है उसी
सेम डीएलएल को आपका इंटरनेट एक्सप्लोरर भी
यूज कर रहा है और फिर भी आपको कई बार कहीं
भी आपको कोई भी प्रॉब्लम देखने को नहीं
मिलती बिकॉज माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ने इसको ऐसे ही
डिजाइन किया हुआ है कभी आपने सोचा नहीं
होगा कि देखिए थ्रेड्स क्या होते हैं
हैंडल्स मैं बताऊंगा थ्रेड्स क्या होते
हैं हैंडल्स क्या होते हैं प्रोसेस लेकिन
आपने कभी यहां पर नोटिस नहीं हुआ इस चीज
को कि इतनी प्रोसेसस इतने थ्रेड्स और इतने
डीएलएस फाइल हैं और एक साथ रनिंग है और
सेम डीएस मल्टीपल प्रोसेसेस यूज कर पा रही
हैं कैसे क्योंकि
आर द हैंडल्स हैंडल्स में कुछ भी हो सकता
है सोच रहे हो मेरा सीपी यूटिलाइज ली 4 पर
हो रहा
है और मेमोरी यूटिलाइजेशन मेरा ओनली कितना
हा 18 जीबी अभी फरा हुआ है भरा हुआ है तो
सोच रहे हो
कि किस तरीके से कितना अच्छी तरीके से
डिजाइन किया हु आपके माइक्रो सॉफ्ट ने तो
आई थिंक की यह चीज भी आपको समझ में आ गई
होगी अब आगे बढ़ते हैं यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है
आदित्य सिंह मैं आपके सवाल का आंसर लास्ट
में दूंगा थोड़ा सा वेट कर सकते हो तो
करना पड़ेगा आपको क्योंकि अभी मैं एक
टॉपिक पढ़ा रहा हूं इस टॉपिक को मुझे अगर
मैं डिस्टर्ब हो जाऊंगा तो हो सकता है
क्या पता मैं जो चीज आपको समझाने की कोशिश
कर रहा हूं वह ना समझा पाऊ
दो यहां तक सबको समझ में आ रहा
है ओ ओके अभी हम आगे बढ़ते हैं अब जैसे ही
आपने क्या किया एक प्रोसेस के ऊपर जो एक
कोड था जो आपका विंडोज था फॉर एग्जांपल
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वड था उस परे जैसे आपने डबल
क्लिक किया तो डबल क्लिक करते एक फाइल
होती है विनवर्ड उसने एक प्रोसेस को
क्रिएट कर दिया और आपकी प्रोसेस क्रिएट हो
गई अब यह प्रोसेस क्या करती है यह प्रोसेस
आपकी शेड्यूलर के पास जाती है जैसे ही एक
प्रोसेस क्रिएट हुई और सबसे पहले किसके
पास जाएगी आपके शेड्यूलर के पास जाएगी अब
ये शेड्यूलर होता क्या है शेड्यूलर इज द
कंट्रोलर हु कंट्रोल्स हु हैज एक्सेस टू द
सीपीयू शेड्यूलर आपका एक कंट्रोल होता है
जो यह कंट्रोल करता है कि जो सीपीयू है
उसको कौन एक्सेस कर सकता है और कौन एक्सेस
नहीं कर सकता उसको कंट्रोल करने का काम
किसका है शेड्यूलर का है एज वी सीन वी हैव
टू 70 प्रोसेसेस आर रनिंग ऑन दिस मशीन दे
ऑल कैन नॉट गेट द सीप एट द सेम टाइम आप
लोगों को क्या लगता है कि 270 प्रोसेस रन
कर रही है मेरी मशीन में अभी 271 प्रोसेस
थी और यह मैं आपको बता रहा हूं कि सारी की
सारी प्रोसेस एक साथ सीपीयू टाइम नहीं ले
सकती एक साथ सीपीयू में लोड नहीं हो सकती
और आपको वह रनिंग कंडीशन में देखने को मिल
रही है वह रन कर रही है और काफी स्मूथली
रन कर रही है ओके
तो सोच कि कितना स्मूथली और बताइए कि कैसे
पॉसिबल है कोई को बताएगा हाउ इ इ
पॉसिबल
देखिए शेड्यूलर इज द मेन कंपोनेंट इन द
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कर्नल शेड्यूलर क्या है
आपका मेन कंपोनेंट होता है ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम कर्नल के अंदर और शेड्यूलर एक्चुअल
में है क्या शेड्यूलर एक एल्गोरिदम है दैट
लुक्स एट एवरी बडी नीडिंग द सीपीयू एंड इट
मेक अ वेरी वेरी गुड चॉइस एंड एफिशिएंट
चॉइस ऑफ हाउ मच टाइम दिस विल गेट इन मतलब
यही है कि ओपंग जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कर्नल
है वो शेड्यूलर को कंट्रोल करता है आपका
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम शेड्यूलर एक ऐसी
एल्गोरिथम्स है जो दे आर ब्राइटेस्ट माइंड
इन द वर्ल्ड जिन्होंने इस एल्गोरिथम को
डिजाइन किया है उन्होंने इस तरीके से
डिजाइन किया है कि जो भी प्रोसेस उसके पास
आएगी तो वह खुद से चूज करता कि कौन सी
प्रोसेस पहले रन करेगी ओके किस प्रोसेस को
कितना टाइम मिलेगा और ताकि जो आपका
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है एक स्टेबल एफिशिएंट वे
में रन कर पाए बिना किसी प्रॉब्लम के
ओके शॉर्ट टर्म एक कंट्रोलर है बेसिकली यू
कैन से ट एक एल्गोरिदम है जो आपकी प्रोसेस
को कंट्रोल करती जब भी कोई आपकी प्रोसेस
क्रिएट होती है सबसे पहले वो आपके
शेड्यूलर के पास जाती है नेक्स्ट अभी मैं
बताता हूं आपको एक्चुअल में हो क्या रहा
आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आपको बताने की कोशिश
करता हूं फॉर एग्जांपल प्रोसेस वन प्रोसेस
टू प्रोसेस थ्री प्रोसेस फोर प्रोसेस फाइव
एंड प्रोसेस n मतलब दे आर लॉट ऑफ
प्रोसेसेस ये सारी सारी प्रोसेस पे आपने
जैसे डबल क्लिक किया ये सबसे पहले किसके
पास जाएंगे शेड्यूलर जो आपकी एल्गोरिथम्स
है आपके स्टूड ने बोला जैसे प्रोसेस 1 2 3
4 5 एक साथ आ गए या जो भी प्रोसेस आई
स्टूड ने बोला वेट
वेट कीजिए मैं डिसाइड करूंगा कि सीपीयू
कौन एक्सेस करेगा कौन एक्सेस नहीं करेगा
जो सीपीयू जो साइकिल्स है सीपीयू को सबसे
पहले कौन रन करेगा कौन नहीं रन कर पाएगा
इसकी डिसीजन अथॉरिटी मेरे पास है सारी
प्रोसेस किसके पास गई शेड्यूलर के पास
शेड्यूलर ने बोला वेट उसके बाद शेड्यूलर
क्या करता है प्रोसेस वन आई प्रायोरिटी
चेक की ओके प्रोसेस वन को सीपीयू साइकिल
दे दी ओके आप इतनी सेकंड के लिए इतनी मिली
सेकंड के लिए इतने नंबर साइकिल क्योंकि
साइकिल में डील करता है सीपीयू आपका क्या
करता है साइकिल में डील करता है इतने नंबर
ऑफ साइकिल दिए ओके आप आपको इतनी साइकिल दए
सीपीयू में रन कीजिए एंड
एग्जिट पूरा टाइम नहीं बोल रहा कि आप एक
काम कीजिए अपनी प्रोग्राम को कंपलीटली रन
करो नहीं प्रोग्राम वन आया सीपीय कुछ मिली
सेकंड कुछ माइक्रो सेकंड के लिए उसने
साइकिल दिए देन आउट बोला फिर से लाइन में
लग जाओ प्रोसेस वन आई रन की और फिर से
लाइन में प्रोसेस टू फिर से शड लर ने उसको
शेड्यूल किया प्रोसेस टू आई कुछ सीपीयू
साइकिल को यूटिलाइज किया अगेन फिर से लाइन
में प्रोसेस थ्री कुछ सीपीयू साइकिल को
यूटिलाइज किया फिर से लाइन में वो किसके
पास प्रोसेस वन टू थ इनके पीछे लाइन में
लग गए क्योंकि प्रायोरिटी सबकी सेम थी
प्रोसेस फॉर आई कुछ सीपीयू साइकिल देन
उसके बाद फिर से अगेन लाइन में ऐसे ही
सारी की सारी प्रोसेस काम करती है फिर से
जैसे ही क्या आएगी फिर से प्रोसेस वन का
टर्न आएगा फिर से नंबर ऑफ सीपीयू साइकिल
ऐसा नहीं कि सेकंड टाइम उसका टन आया तो वह
अ ज्यादा नंबर ऑफ़ साइकिल मिलेंगे नहीं यह
डिसाइड कौन करेगा आपका शेड्यूलर की जो
सीपीयू है कितनी देर के लिए व यूटिलाइज
करने के लिए मिलेगा तो मिली सेकंड माइक्रो
सेकंड जो भी इसने दिया शेड्यूलर ने डिसाइड
किया फिर से रन किया फिर से लाइन में रन
एंड फिर से लाइन में रन एंड लाइन यह
साइकिल चलता रहता है आपके सीपीयू में जो
भी आपने देखा था अभी 271 प्रोसेस ऐसे चल
रही है हमारे सीपीयू में जो मेरी मशीन है
मेरी मशीन में जो शेड्यूलर है ऐसे ही
डिसाइड कर रहा है हमें लग रहा है कि ओके
यह सारी तो रनिंग है यार एक साथ रन कर रही
है अच्छा खासा एक ग्राफिक मोशन चल रहा है
और मैं वर्ड एमएस वर्ड यूज कर रहा तो एमएस
वर्ड यूज कर कर पा रहा हूं अभी देखिए
पीपीटी अच्छे से चल रही है और
वर्क्स बिकॉज इसका एक कारण है बिकॉज इट इज
रनिंग
एट 2.6 गगा हर्ज जो आपका सीपीयू है व 2.6
आज चल तो 5 गगा ह तक जाता है ना 2.6 तो
नॉर्मल रहता है
3.2 3.4 तक चलते हैं तो इतनी गीगाहर्टज की
स्पीड से आपका सीपीयू रन कर रहा है इट्स
रनिंग ए सच हाई स्पीड यू आर थिंकिंग दे आर
मूविंग व्हाट एवर दे आर डू आपको लग रहा है
कि यह सारी की सारी मोशन में है लेकिन ऐसा
नहीं है आपका जो शेड्यूलर है शेड्यूल कर
रहा है प्रोसेस को इतनी देर के लिए यूज
करो आउट यूज करो आउट यूज करो आउट फिर से
लाइन में लगो यूज करो फिर से लाइन में लगो
यूज करो फिर से ऐसे चल रहा है मेरी 271
प्रोसेस के साथ और ये इतना फास्ट हो रहा
है 2.6 गगा हर्ट की स्पीड से पर सेकंड समझ
रहे इतने इतनी स्पीड से काम हो रहा है कि
आपको पता नहीं चल रहा अगर आपने कभी देखा
होगा कि ऑल टाइम में जब मूवीज देखी जाती
थी मैंने देखा नहीं है बट अगर थिएटर्स
देखा होगा कि एक रील होगी और रील्स के ऊपर
क्या है कि हर पॉइंट के लिए अलग-अलग फोटो
डिजाइन किया हुआ है लेकिन उसको जब क्या है
कि एक स्पीड पर एक आरपीएम प उसको टर्न
किया जाता है तो लगता है कि प्रोजेक्टर पे
ओके दे आर मूविंग कि अभी ये मूवमेंट हो
गया लाइक दैट सीपीयू भी ऐसे सेम उसी
फिलोसोफी पे काम करता है आपका सीपीओ भी कि
आपको लग रहा है कि एक परफेक्ट फ्लूइड मोशन
है कि एक परफेक्ट रन ंग कंडीशन में है बट
ऐसा नहीं है हर एक प्रोसेस को एक साइकिल
टाइम मिलता है नंबर ऑफ साइकिल मिलती है
देन फिर से लाइन में लगती है ये इतना
फास्ट हो रहा है कि यह आपकी जो आंखें हैं
वोह चीजें देख नहीं पाएंगी क्योंकि आपकी
आंखें इसको कभी भी कैप्चर नहीं कर पाएंगी
ओके यस तो
अभी थोड़ी सी हिस्ट्री के बारे में पढ़ते
हैं कि विंडोज मैक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हो चाहे आपका कोई
भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हो वो तीन टाइप्स के
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर ही काम करता है एक तो
प्रिमिटिव मल्टीटास्किंग सेकंड रियल टाइम
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम थर्ड कोऑपरेटिव
मल्टीटास्किंग रियल टाइम ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
खास कर कि आपके जो न्यूक्लियर प्लांट है
या आपके सैटेलाइट एरियाज है या जो
मिलिट्री के लिए जो
हाईली सेंसिटिव एरियाज है जहां पर जरूरत
है लाइव ट्रैकिंग या लाइव उन चीजों के लिए
वहां पर यूज किए जाते हैं बाकी आपको
नॉर्मली देखने को नहीं मिलेंगे रेयरली बट
प्रिमिटिव मल्टीटास्किंग और कोऑपरेटिव
मल्टीटास्किंग यह क्या होते हैं मैं आपको
बताता हूं दीज आर द थ्री टाइप्स ऑफ डिंग
सिस्टम इन द वर्ल्ड यही तीन टाइप के
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम अवेलेबल है आपके पूरे के
पूरी दुनिया में टुडे ऑल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
लाइक
ट मल्टीटास्किंग है व्ट डट मींस इसका मतलब
क्या है इट मींस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है टोटल
कंट्रोल ऑन द प्रोसेसेस हु गोज इन टू द
सीपीयू हु हैज एक्सेस टू द सीपीयू टाइम
बिल्कुल जो मैंने आपको बताया फॉर एग्जांपल
क्रम इंटरनेट एक्सप्लोरर और वर्ड है तो
सबसे पहले प्रोग्राम वन आया क्रम क्रम
आपके पास शेड्यूलर के पास है शेड्यूलर ने
क्या किया ओके यू टेक फ्यू साइकिल इतनी
देर के लिए उसने साइकिल दी देन उसके बाद
प्रोग्राम टू यहां से प्रोग्राम टू थोड़ी
देर के लिए रन किया फिर प्रोग्राम थ रन
किया देन अगेन प्रोग्राम वन प्रोग्राम टू
प्रोग्राम थ इस तरीके से कंटीन्यूअसली काम
चलता रहता है आपकी मशीन में और इतनी स्पीड
से होता है जो आप देख नहीं सकते और इस
इससे क्या है कि सारा का सारा कंट्रोल
किसके पास है आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के पास
ठीक है आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिसाइड कर
रहा है विद द हेल्प ऑफ शेड्यूलर कि सीपीयू
कौन कितनी देर के लिए यूज कर सकता है और
किसको एक्सेस है सीपीयू का किसको एक्सेस
नहीं है ओके अभी बात करते हैं रहा अभी ये
एग्जांपल आपको समझ में आ गया होगा लाइक
दैट यू हैव सी परफेक्ट फ्लूइड मोशन
मल्टीटास्किंग ऑफ वंडरफुल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
बिकॉज ऑल ऑफ दिस डन ऑन गिगा हर्ट्ज स्पीड
बट इन रियलिटी इट वर्क्स लाइक दिस रियलिटी
में ऐसे काम करता है लेकिन आपको ऐसा लग
रहा है कि एक पर एक परफेक्ट मल्टीटास्किंग
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है मैं जितने भी चाहूं
उतने प्रोग्राम रन कर पा रहा हूं और मेरे
को कहीं पर भी कहीं पर हैंग या कहीं पर भी
रुकी हुई चीजें नजर नहीं आती लेकिन ऐसा
नहीं है यह इस तरीके से ही काम करता है
लेकिन यह काम इतनी स्पीड हो रहा है इतनी
स्पीड है 3.2 गगा हर्ज या 2.6 गगा हर्ज जो
आपकी आंखें कभी भी कैप्चर नहीं कर सकती
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है या नहीं है प्लीज
बताइए
बताइए मैं आपका डाउट लेता हूं किसी कोई
डाउट है इसमें
अभी यार आप वेब डेवलपमेंट सीख रहे हो तो
आपको एथिकल हाइकिंग में आने की जरूरत ही
क्या है छोड़िए
नहीं डिस कनेक्शन नहीं होता मानसिंह जैसे
मैंने आपको बताया आपका सीपीयू ऐसे ही
एजेक्ट काम करता है ये डिसाइड कौन करेगा
आपका शेड्यूलर शेड्यूलर एक बहुत ही
पावरफुल एल्गोरिथम्स होती है वही डिसाइड
करेगी कि कौन जाएगा कौन नहीं
जाएगा किसी का कोई सवाल है यहां तक प्लीज
पूछ लीजिए हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं फिर किसी
को ऐसा लगता कि मुझे कुछ समझ में नहीं
आया अरे रम को यूज करने के आपकी देखो रम
शेड्यूलर यूज नहीं करता यार शेड्यूलर
सिर्फ शेड्यूल करता है रम क्या अंदर आपकी
प्रोसेस लोड हो जाती है उसके बाद सीपीयू
यूटिलाइजेशन रम और सीपीयू के बीच में कैचे
मेमोरी होती है जो नंबर ऑफ रजिस्टर्स होते
हैं वहां पर होता
है और किसी कोई
सवाल मुझे पता यह टॉपिक ऐसा है इसमें इतने
सवाल और जवाब हो सकते हैं अनलिमिटेड बिकॉज
इट इज वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग किसी चीज के बारे
में जानना इज वेरी वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग
तो किसी का कोई सवाल नहीं है तो हम आगे
कंटिन्यू करें
बताइए यह चीज आई थिंक किसी को नहीं पता था
सबको लगता था कि ओके मैं जैसे डबल क्लिक
कर रहा हूं
और कि मैं मशीन मेरी अभी फ्लूड मोशन
कंटीन्यू सली ऐसे रन कर नहीं लेकिन
एक्चुअल में ऐसे ही होता
है तो ए के कुमारी जी आप आई डोंट नो कि यू
आर मैन और वुमेन और अगर आपको पसंद नहीं आ
रहा है क्या मैं पढ़ा रहा हूं तो मे बी यू
कैन लीव आप छोड़ सकते हो
अभी मैं पढ़ा रहा हूं फंडामेंटल्स ऑफ
विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ट वेरी वेरी
इंपोर्टेंट फॉर एनी पेन टेस्टर इवन एनी
सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट ओनली ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम यह कर्न लेवल की बात
है ओके अभी हम बात करते हैं कंटिन्यू चलते
हैं फिर सेशन को कंटिन्यू करते हैं
नेक्स्ट अभी मैं आपको बताता हूं कि 20 से
30 साल पहले चाहे मैक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम था
विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम था कोई भी
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम था सारे के सारे
कोऑपरेटिव ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम थे अभी
कोऑपरेटिव ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में होता क्या
था कि जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्या था कि फॉर
एग्जांपल प्रोग्राम वन है प्रोग्राम टू रन
कर रहा है तो प्रोग्राम वन ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम गिव्स कंट्रोल टू द प्रोग्राम वन
पूरा कंट्रोल प्रोग्राम वन को दे देता था
प्रोग्राम न क्या करता था प्रोग्राम वन
परफॉर्म सम फंक्शंस देन रिटर्न्स कंट्रोल
टू द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फिर से उस कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को दे देता प्रोग्राम रन
कर करता अपना प्रोग्राम वन कंप्लीट
प्रोग्राम रन करता है और थोड़ी देर के लिए
उसके बाद ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को कंट्रोल दे
देता था अब फिर से ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्या
करता था प्रोग्राम टू को कंट्रोल दे देता
था प्रोग्राम टू क्या करता था अपना कोड रन
करता था फिर से कंट्रोल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
को देता था तो उसके बाद फिर से ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम गिव्स कंट्रोल बैक टू द प्रोग्राम
वन तो ऐसा चलता था आपके कॉपरेट टिव
मल्टीटास्किंग के अंदर अभी मैंने आपको
बताया जो फ्लूइड मोशन परफेक्ट इतनी हाई
स्पीड वो था प्रिमिटिव मल्टीटास्किंग बट
अभी मैं बात कर रहा हूं 20 से 30 साल पहले
कोऑपरेटिव म मल्टीटास्किंग का यूज कि तब
इस तरीके से काम होता था यहां पर सबसे
बड़ी डिसएडवांटेज क्या थी कि फॉर एग्जांपल
अगर किसी हैकर ने या किसी मशियल व्यक्ति
ने मशियल मेंटालिटी के व्यक्ति ने एक
ट्रोजन वायरस मालवेयर व्हाट एवर यू थिंक
कोई भी एक्सप्लोइट एक मिशिस एप्लीकेशन
डिजाइन की उस प्रोग्राम को रन करवा दिया
तो कभी वापस कंट्रोल देगा ही नहीं सीपीयू
को आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
को हमेशा उस मशीन को अपने कंट्रोल में
रखेगा तो दैट इज द बिग प्रॉब्लम क्योंकि
कोई भी अगर एक बैड एप्लीकेशन है अगर उसने
एक बार कंट्रोल कर लिया बाय मिस्टेक ली तो
उसकी मर्जी है कब कंट्रोल देगा
फिर यही था ना कोऑपरेटिव मल्टीटास्किंग
सबसे बड़ा सिक्योरिटी रिस्क था इसलिए आया
आपका प्रिमिटिव मल्टीटास्किंग उसमें सब
कुछ डिसीजन अथॉरिटी आपका शेड्यूलर है
शेड्यूलर के शेड्यूलर के अलावा कोई भी इस
चीज को डिसाइड नहीं
करता नेक्स्ट अभी हम बात करते हैं टिल नाउ
वी लर्न प्रोसे
गो टू द शेड्यूलर
एंड से आई नीड टू रन बट डज इट रियली रन
योरसेल्फ आपको क्या लगता है कि एक प्रोसेस
है प्रोसेस शेड्यूलर के पास जाती है
शेड्यूलर को बोलती है कि मुझे रन करना है
तो आप मेरा सवाल यह है क्या लगता है कि
आपको यहां पर प्रोसेस रन कर रही
है क्या यहां पर प्रोसेस रन कर रही है
बताइए अ इस चीज को मत देखना नीचे वाली
चीजों को ओनली खुद से सोच के बताइए
प्रोसेस शेड्यूलर के पास जा रही है
शेड्यूलर सीपीओ टाइम प्रोवाइड करता है रन
करने के लिए तो क्या सच में प्रोसेस रन
करती
है क्या सच में प्रोसेस रन करती
है कोई मुझको बताएगा
कोई मुझे बताएगा क्या सच में प्रोसेस रन
करती
है यस आंसर दिख गया मुझे पता
है नहीं क्योंकि इट रंस द कोड इनसाइड दैट
प्रोसेस प्रोसेस रन नहीं करती उसके अंदर
जो कोड है जिसको हम क्या बोलते हैं
थ्रेड्स जिसको हम क्या बोलते हैं थ्रेड्स
रन करते हैं बिकॉज वी ऑलरेडी नो ए प्रोसेस
इज ए वर्चुलाइज्ड कंटेनर इट पुल अप द
डीएलएल इट पुल अप द थ्रेड्स एंड दीज र द
दीज आर द फाइल्स व्हिच आर रनिंग ओके
बेसिकली क्या होता है कि प्रोसेस रन नहीं
करती प्रोसेस के अंदर थ्रेड्स होते हैं
थ्रेड्स वो कोड होते हैं वो फाइल्स होती
हैं वो डीएलएस होते हैं जो रन करते हैं
क्योंकि प्रोसेस तो एक कंटेनर है कंटेनर
के अंदर कोड है वो कोड रन करता है क्लियर
यहां तक प्रोसेस आपकी रन नहीं करती वो कोड
रन करता है ठीक है क्योंकि आपकी प्र
प्रोसेस क्रिएट होगी उसके बाद जो कोड उसके
अंदर आपकी डील्स भी लोड हो जाती है उसके
रिक्वायरमेंट का डाटा लोड हो जाता है उसके
रिक्वायरमेंट का कोड लोड हो जाता है वो जो
रन करता है फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मैं आपको एक
और चीज समझाता हूं एक प्रोसेस वन है जिसके
अंदर नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड कितने हैं वन है एक
थ्रेड प्रोग्राम है ये प्रोसेस टू है
जिसके अंदर थ्री ड ये थ्री थ्रेड
प्रोग्राम है मतलब ये ऑल्ड टाइम की मेथोड
के साथ डिजाइन किया प्रोग्राम है जिसके
अंदर ओनली वन थ्रेड है यह मल्टी थ्रेडेड
प्रोग्राम है जो आपको सुना होगा जब भी आप
प्रोग्रामिंग करते हो कि मल्टी थ्रेडेड
प्रोग्रामिंग अच्छी होती है ये साइमन असली
एक साथ
कई ऑप्शंस एक साथ कई चीजें कर सकते हो आप
प्रोग्राम्स में तो यह है तो व फास्ट होते
हैं तो यह मल्टी थ्रेडेड प्रोग्राम है यह
सिंगल प्रोग्राम जब ये क्या वन इट गोस टू
द सीपीयू एंड सीपीयू इज ए मल्टी थ्रेडेड
कैपेबल प्रोसेस इट रंस जीरो थ थ्रेड्स एट
द सेम टाइम क्या होता है कि कभी भी आपने
आर्किटेक्चर देखी होगी आजकल के सीपीयू की
नॉर्मली क्या आपने देखा होगा टू कोर
प्रोसेसर विद हाइपर थ्रेडेड टेक्नोलॉजी
इसका मतलब क्या होता है कि एक आपका जो एक
कोर है वह एक्ट एज ए टू सीपीयू एक्ट लाइक
ए टू सीपीयू दो कोर हो गया मतलब उसके अंदर
चार सीपीयू है हाइपर थड अगर ऐसा लिखा है
आपके डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपके जो फीचर्स है
जो भी आप लैपटॉप या जो भी मशीन खरीदते हो
अगर वहां पर लिखा आता कि टू कोर हा हाइपर
थ्रेडेड टेक्नोलॉजी मतलब क्या है कि एक
कोर का मतलब दो सीपीयू है दो कोर का मतलब
चार सीपीयू अभी इसके अंदर फॉर एग्जांपल ये
मेरा सीपीयू है इसके अंदर टू कोड प्रोसेसर
इसका मतलब चार सीपीयू है एक साथ तो एक साथ
ये कितने रन कर सकता है प्रोग्राम चार
प्रोग्राम रन कर सकता है अभी यहां पर क्या
है यहां पर क्या है कि इसके पास तीन थ्रेड
है इसके पास वन है तो एक साथ क्या कर सकता
है इस इस पूरे प्रोग्राम की तीनों की
तीनों थ्रेड को एक साथ रन कर सकता है प्लस
में इस प्रोग्राम की जो सिंगल थ्रेड बच गई
उसको भी कर सकता है मतलब ये दोनों प्रोसेस
एक साथ रन कर सकती है ये तीन तीन और एक
चार चारों थ्रेड एक साथ रन कर सकती है
कोर्स आपके जो सीपीयू की कैपेबिलिटी है
हार्डवेयर कैपेबिलिटी है टू कोर प्रोसेसर
विद हाइपर थ्रेडिंग टेक्नोलॉजी अ ये हाइपर
थ्रेडिंग टेक्नोलॉजी होती क्या है ये भी
मैं आपको अपकमिंग क्लास में समझाऊं अभी
अभी समझाने वाला हूं तो देखिए हाइपर
थ्रेडिंग और मल्टी कोर सीपीयू का मतलब
क्या होता है हाइपर थ्रेडिंग टेक्नोलॉजी
इज ए टेक्निक दैट इनेबल्स ए सिंगल सीपीयू
टू एक्ट लाइक मल्टीपल सीपीयू हाइपर
थ्रेडिंग की जो टेक्नोलॉजी आई है उसका
मतलब यही है कि एक सिंबल सी जो एक सिंगल
सीपीयू है वो मल्टीपल सीपीयू की तरह एक्ट
करता है ए सीपीयू इज मेड अप ऑफ मेनी मेनी
स्मॉलर कंपोनेंट्स एट एनी गिवन ऑफ टाइम वन
ऑफ दीज कंपोनेंट्स माइट बी बीजी अभी हो
सकता है कि अब जब ये टेक्नोलॉजी आई तो
इसके सा इसके अंदर बहुत सारे छोटे-छोटे
कंपोनेंट्स है अभी एक सिंगल सीपीयू
मल्टीपल सीपीयू तरह एक्ट हो सकता एक्ट कर
रहा है तो इसका मतलब हो सकता है इसके कुछ
कंपोनेंट्स कहीं पर बिजी हो और बाकी जो
बचे हुए कंपोनेंट्स है वो वेट कर रहे हो
कि हमें भी यूटिलाइज किया जाए इट इज
पॉसिबिलिटी
हाइपर थ्रेडिंग इनेबल्स डिफरेंट
सीपीयू सीपीयू पार्ट्स टू वर्क ऑन डिफरेंट
टास्क कंक्रेंस हाइपर थ्रेडिंग का मतलब
क्या है कि एक साथ कई प्रोग्राम को रन
किया जा सकता है इन दिस वे ए सीपीयू विद
हाइपर थ्रेडिंग अपीयर्स टू बी मोर देन वन
सीपीयू सीपीयू विद हाइपर थ्रेडिंग हैज टू
सेट्स ऑफ सर्किट्स दैट कीप ट्रैक ऑफ द
सीपीयू स्टेट यह ऐसे बस समझने के लिए है
मोस्ट ऑफ यू हैव राइट नाउ टू सी यूज एंड
ईच ऑफ दज आर हाइपर बेसिकली आज के टाइम में
99 पर क्या है सीपीय क्या है टू कोर हाइपर
थ सीपीयू अवेलेबल सी है दैट इज वई हमारे
जो टास्क है इतने फास्ट परफॉर्म हो पा रहे
हैं सो एट एट द वेरी मोस्ट य यर सीपीयू
कैन डू फोर थिंग्स एट ए टाइम यह कॉमन टू
कॉमन सीपीयू की आर्किटेक्चर मिलेगी आज के
टाइम में यूजिंग दिस टेक्नोलॉजी वी आर
सॉल्विंग वन प्रॉब्लम वी आर नॉट द क्लॉक
स्पीड ऑफ द सीपीयू किसी को पता है क्लॉक
स्पीड क्या होती है डज एनी वन क्लॉक स्पीड
क्या होती
है अभी हम प्रॉब्लम तो सॉल्व कर रहे हैं
विद द हेल्प ऑफ हाइपर थ्रेडिंग बट हम अपनी
क्लॉक स्पीड को कभी भी नहीं बढ़ाते तो
क्लॉक स्पीड क्या होती है
यस बिल्कुल राजू यही चीजें हैं वहां पर भी
आप कोड सिलेक्ट इसीलिए करते
हो क्लॉक स्पीड जब भी आपने अभी मैंने आपको
बताया कि आपने एक फ्रीक्वेंसी देखी देखी
होगी या डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपने क्या देखा
होगा कि इस मशीन की कैपेबिलिटी है
2.92 3 गगा 5 गगा दैट इज योर क्लॉक स्पीड
क्लॉक स्पीड देखिए फॉर एग्जांपल मैं अभी
फप का पर जाता हूं चलो आपको दिखाता हूं फप
का आप जाते हो ओके एंड फप का पर मैंने
क्या किया एक कोई भी लैपटॉप में सर्च करता
हूं फॉर एग्जांपल कोई भी लैपटॉप या कुछ भी
एंड ए
सर यह लैपटॉप है आ3 है यहां पर आप देखते
हो अगर एक चीज आपने नोटिस की होगी कभी भी
रीड मोर एंड आ3 फ डीड फ यह क्या है कभी
कभी नोटिस करते ही नहीं आप
मैक्सिमम क्लॉक स्पीड इसकी 4.5 जा सकती है
मैक्स टू मैक्स ट इज क्लॉक
स्पीड सबको पता चला ट इज योर क्लॉक
स्पीड ट इज योर क्लॉक
स्पीड इसलिए कभी भी आपने नोटिस किया होगा
कि प्रॉब्लम तो हम सॉल्व कर रहे विद द
हेल्प ऑफ हाइपर थ्रेडिंग बट इस क्लॉक
स्पीड को हम कभी भी नहीं बढ़ाते इसको
बढ़ाने के बजाय हम क्या कर रहे हैं नंबर
ऑफ कोर्स बढ़ा रहे हैं फॉर एग्जांपल मेरे
मशीन की अगर मैं बात करूं तो मेरी मशीन 24
थ्रेड मेरी मशीन एक साथ रन कर सकती है 24
मे भी और कोर में भी ज्यादा ही होंगे एटली
आई डोंट रिमेंबर तो अगर मैं तो यह चीज
आपको बता दे वेट ए मिनट
एंड माय मशीन इज
ट यस सर चलो मैं किसी भी एक लैपटॉप की बात
कर लेते
हैं
आना 13 जन लैपटॉप एंड फॉर एग्जांपल मैं
इसी की बात करता हूं
[संगीत]
या यह गेमिंग लैपटॉप है तो आपने कभी भी
नोटिस किया होगा यहां पर लिखा होगा कहीं
पर लिखा होगा थ्रेड और ये सारी चीज रहती
है
इसकी ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट पर आपको य
इंफॉर्मेशन 100% मिलेगी कितने नंबर ऑफ कोर
और यह आपको देखने को मिलेगी यह हमेशा
देखने को मिलता है नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स कितने
रन कर सकता है एक साथ तो इंफॉर्मेशन होती
है आपकी तो ये वही चीज है इसलिए हमेशा आप
क्या करते हैं कि प्रॉब्लम सॉल्व तो हो
रही है आज के टाइम में लेकिन कोई भी क्लॉक
स्पीड को नहीं बढ़ाता तो कोई मेरे को ये
बता सकता है कि क्लॉक स्पीड हम क्यों नहीं
बढ़ा
सकते डज एनी वन टेल मी कि वई हम क्लॉक
स्पीड को क्यों नहीं बढ़ा सकते ठीक हम
नंबर ऑफ कोर्स को बढ़ा रहे हैं बट क्लॉक
स्पीड को हम क्यों नहीं बढ़ा रहे अभी मे
ख्याल से मैक्स फ्रीक्वेंसी जो क्लॉक
स्पीड होगी 5 गगा हर्ज है इससे ज्यादा तो
कोई मैक्स नहीं दे रहा होगा वो भी हाई
यूसेज में वई क्योंकि अगर हम क्लॉक स्पीड
को बढ़ाएंगे उससे क्या होगा हीट जनरेट
होगी अब जितनी ज्यादा हीट जनरेट होगी उतने
ज्यादा हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा उसके लिए
कूलिंग
की वो करनी पड़े कलिंग फैन लगाने पड़ेंगे
क्लॉक स्पीड ज्यादा होगी पता चला कि एक
छोटा सा सीपीयू है उसके ऊपर आपने बहुत
बड़े-बड़े कूलिंग फैन लगाने पड़ रहे हैं
मतलब उसका सोचिए कि साइज क्या होगा क्लॉक
स्पीड बढ़ाने का ना बढ़ाने का यह रीजन है
ज्यादा क्लॉक स्पीड होगी तो क्या होगा
आपका सीपीयू हीट अप करेगा अगर आपका सीपीयू
हीट अप करेगा तो वहां पर उसको क्या चाहिए
कूलिंग चाहिए और कूल करने के लिए आपको
नंबर ऑफ फैंस या उसके लिए अलग से कुछ और अ
चीज की व्यवस्था करनी पड़ेगी जिससे क्या
आगी उसकी हीट को मेंटेन किया जा सके दैट
इज व्हाई कि सभी जितने भी आजकल हार्डवेयर
कंपनीज हैं क्लॉक स्पीड को बढ़ाने का जो
आईडिया है उसको बंद कर रही है रदर देन वो
नंबर ऑफ कोर्स बढ़ा देती है क्लॉक स्पीड
सेम है नंबर ऑफ कोर्स बढ़ा देते हैं काम
उतना ही फास्ट हो रहा है क्योंकि क्लॉक
स्पीड बढ़ाने का मतलब है कि उसकी कूलिंग
कैपेसिटी भी बढ़ानी पड़ेगी और कूलिंग
कैपेसिटी आज के टाइम में आपको पता है कि
कितनी हार्ड है पॉसिबल है बट कैसे बढ़ाओ ग
उससे वेट बढ़ेगा मशीन का बहुत सारी चीजें
बढ़ेंगी तो इसलिए क्लॉक स्पीड आप इसलिए जो
क्लॉक स्पीड का जो आईडिया है सभी उसको हटा
रहे
हैं ऑन ए सिंगल प्रोसेसर मल्टी थ्रेडिंग
जनरली ओकर्स बाय ए टाइम डिवीजन
मल्टीप्लेक्सिंग आपकी ये इंफॉर्मेशन के
लिए है कि पहले जब सिंगल प्रोसेसर होता था
तो वो भी मल्टी थ्रेडिंग रन करता था लेकिन
वहां पर एक टेक्नोलॉजी यूज की जाती थी
टाइम डिवीजन मल्टीप्लेक्सिंग टेक्नोलॉजी
का यूज करके वह रन कर पाते थे मल्टी थ्रेड
को एक सिंगल प्रोसेसर पे नाउ एडेज क्या है
मल्टीपल प्रोसेसर है द सिंगल द प्रोसेसर
स्विचस बिटवीन डिफरेंट थ्रेड वो
कंटीन्यूअसली क्या करता था कांटेक्ट
स्विचिंग करता रहता था बहुत ज्यादा फास्ट
दिस कंटक्ट स्विचिंग जनरली हैपेंस
फ्रीक्वेंसी
द थ्रेड्स एंड टास्क एज रनिंग एट द सेम
टाइम ओके ऑन ए मल्टी प्रोसेस और मल्टी कोर
सिस्टम की हम बात करते हैं थ्रेड्स कैन बी
रन करंट अब सिंगल कोर की बात करते थे तो
हम एक टेक्नोलॉजी यूज करते थे टाइम डिवीजन
मल्टीप्लिकेशन उसकी हेल्प से हम सेम
फंक्शन अचीव कर पा रहे थे लेकिन जब मल्टी
प्रोसेस की हम बात करें और जब मल्टी कोर
सिस्टम की बात करें तो हम क्या कर सकते
हैं एक साथ मल्टीपल थड्स को एक साथ सेल्टन
असली रन कर सकते हैं तो ऑटोमेटिक वहां पर
जो एक टेक्नोलॉजी थी टाइम डिवीजन
मल्टीप्लेक्सिंग उसकी जरूरत नहीं है सो दी
हार्डवेयर टेक्नोलॉजी हैज बिगन टू इंप्रूव
देन ऑल द सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलपर शिफ्ट टू मल्टी
जैसे-जैसे आपकी जो हार्डवेयर टेक्नोलॉजी
बढ़ती गई उसमें इंप्रूवमेंट होते गए
वैसे-वैसे आपके जो सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलपर्स है
उन्होंने भी अपने आप में इंप्रूवमेंट ले
लिया अपने आप को अपडेट कर लिया किसमें कि
उन्होंने सभी जितने भी एप्लीकेशन डेवलप की
जाती है जितने भी सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलप किए
जाते हैं वो सारे क्या होते हैं मल्टी
थ्रेड होते हैं सबको पता है अब आज कोई
प्रोग्रामिंग करने बैठ जाएगा और सिंगल
थ्रेडेड एप्लीकेशन बनाएगा तो उसको कोई
कंपनी हायर तक नहीं क्योंकि बोलेगा सर
मेरे को मल्टी थ्रेडिंग तो आती नहीं
क्योंकि मल्टी थ्रेडिंग कंपलसरी है किसी
भी डेवलपर के लिए दैट इज भाई कि हर कोई
सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलपर मल्टी थ्रेडिंग पर
ज्यादा फोकस करता है यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है या किसी को कोई डाउट
है यहां तक सबका क्लियर है या किसी को कोई
डाउट है सेशन बोर्डिंग तो नहीं लग रहा है
किसी
को किसी को लग रहा है कि सर मुझे सेशन बोर
लग रहा है बोरिंग फील हो रहा है एनी वन
किसी को लगता है कि इंटरेस्टेड नहीं है आज
इंटरेस्ट नहीं बन रहा सर क्या पढ़ा रहे हो
हमें समझ में नहीं आ रहा ऐसा तो कुछ नहीं
है थ्रेड क्या होता है मैं आपको थ्रेड
क्या होता है कि जो कोड है जो कोड रन करते
हो ना आप वही आपका थ्रेड होता है पाइथन
में जो कोड रन करते हो या सी प्लस प्लस
में जो कोड है या जो आपका जावा में है वह
जो कोड है वह थ्रेड
है समझ में
आया सबको मजा आ रहा है
सबको क्लास में मजा आ रहा नहीं आ रहा
बताइए इसलिए मैं सेशन को ज्यादा लंबे खीचू
नहीं एक से सवा घंटा ही सेशन को डिलीवर
करूंगा क्योंकि यह कुछ टॉपिक्स है जितना
शॉर्ट हम इसको पढ़ाएंगे उतना ज्यादा इसमें
मजा
आएगा
ओके अभी कभी भी आपने देखा होगा कि आपका
चाहे कोई भी टास्क मैनेजर हो कोई भी
रिसोर्स मॉनिटर टूल्स हो सारे के सारे एक
ही काम कर रहे हैं सारे के सारे किस चीज
को मॉनिटर कर रहे हैं कि फ पांच हार्डवेयर
सब सिस्टम होते हैं देयर आर फाइव
हार्डवेयर सिस्टम सब सिस्टम्स सीपीयू
मेमोरी डिस्क नेटवर्क और वीडियोज मतलब
आपका ग्राफिक कार्ड समझ में आया कि चाहे
कोई भी टूल्स उठा लो आप अ आपके रिसोर्सेस
को मॉनिटर करने के लिए सभी के सभी किन पे
इन पांच हार्डवेयर पे क्या करते हैं फोकस
करते हैं यह पांच हार्डवेयर कौन से आपके
सीपीयू मेमोरी डिस्क को नेटवर्क वीडियोज
इन्हीं पर ही क्या करते हैं फोकस करते हैं
यह फर इंफॉर्मेशन आपको बता रहा हूं इसके
अलावा कभी आपने कोई देखा कि कोई कमांड
लाइन हो चाहे कोई भी हो आपने जब कमांड में
आ तो नेटवर्क को मॉनिटर करते हो कौन-कौन
सी प्रोसेस रन कर रही है प्रोसेस को
मॉनिटर करते हो या डिस्क यूसेज या मेमोरी
या सीपीयू यही चीज तो आप यूज कर रहे हो ये
चीज मैं आपको समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं
कि सीपीयू में मेमोरी में डिस्क में
नेटवर्क ये सब चीज वही चल रही है ओके तो
अभी हम
नेक्स्ट आगे बढ़े या सेशन को आज इधर ही
एंड करें
कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट चीजें हैं य आगे बढ़ना
है
बताइए सेशन को एंड करना है या आगे बढ़ना
बताइए
तो एक
इंपॉर्टेंट टर्म्स है कुछ और इंपॉर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन है जो मैं आपको पास ऑन करना
चाहता हूं तो प्रोसेस से रिलेटेड जो भी
कुछ अभी पढ़ाया उसमें थोड़ा सा और आगे
बढ़ते हैं तो सबसे पहले एक चीज आपने देखी
होगी नहीं देखी होगी तो आप देख लीजिए क्
नहीं देखी होगी आपने यह एक सिस्टम आइडियल
प्रोसेस होती है आपके आपके मशीन के अंदर
एक सिस्टम आइडियल प्रोसेस होती है दिस इज
वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट प्रोसेस इन योर
डेस्कटॉप मशीन बिकॉज दिस इज द प्रोसेस दैट
विल ऑलवेज टेक अप सीपीयू टाइम व्हेन नोबडी
एल्स वांटेड जब किसी को भी सीपीयू टाइम
नहीं चाहिए उस समय आपकी जोस्ट सिस्टम
आइडियल प्रोसेस होती है आप नीचे देख पा
रहे होंगे सिस्टम आइडियल प्रोसेस यह इसको
यूज करती है मतलब जब आपका सीपीयू खाली
बैठा हुआ है उसके पास कोई भी प्रोसेस नहीं
आ रही उसके पास कुछ भी काम नहीं है उस समय
सिस्टम आइडियल प्रोसेस रन करती है पूरे
पूरे सीपीयू को यूज करती है इट इज अ
प्रोसेस एंड इस प्रोसेस के अंदर थ्रेड्स
भी है एंड इट इज डिजाइंड टू टेक अप द
शेड्यूलर व्हेन नोबडी एल्स इज यूजिंग द
सीपीयू ट्राई टू अंडरस्टैंड द फैक्ट इ यू
आर रनिंग ए सीपीयू विद क्लॉक स्पीड 3.2
बिलियन टाइम्स सेकंड समझने की कोशिश कीजिए
कि आपने ऐसी मशीन ली है जिसकी क्लॉक स्पीड
3.2 बिलियन टाइम से सेकंड है ठीक है और
आपने उसको 50000 से लेकर लाखों रुपए लगाए
एक मशीन के ऊपर और एक छोटी सी वोह जो
सीपीयूसी प आपने पैसे लगाए हैं तो उसको
खाली कैसे छोड़ सकते
हो उसको हमेशा एंगेज रखना ना अभी मेरे केस
में आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा मेरी
दूसरी मशीन का स्क्रीनशॉट है एक टूल के
प्रोसेस एक्सप्लोरर नाम का एक टूल्स है
उससे मैंने लिया हुआ है तोय 98 पर कंजू
दिखा रहा है क्यों दिखा रहा है क्योंकि उस
टाइम पर मे सीपीयू में इसके अलावा कुछ भी
प्रोग्राम्स या कोई भी एप्लीकेशन रन नहीं
कर रही थी इसलिए जब मैं सीपीयू आइडियल है
उस केस में मैं जो सिस्टम सिस्टम आइडियल
प्रोसेस है वह रन करती है बोलती है कि ओके
जब किसी को सीपीयू टाइम नहीं चाहिए मुझे
दे दीजिए मैं रन करूंगी ठीक है
क्योंकि इतने महंगे सिस्टम को आपको खाली
ना छोड़ना पड़े आपके पैसे यूटिलाइजेशन हो
क्योंकि सीपीयू आपने पैसे लगाए और उसको
खाली छोड़ दिया क्या फायदा ट इज वई दिस
प्रोसेस इज रनिंग ऑल द टाइम्स जब भी आप
सीपीयू को फ्री छोड़ोगे यह प्रोसेस
स्टार्ट हो
जाएगी बट यू यू विल नेवर फाइंड दिस
प्रोसेस सर्वर लेकिन सर्वर के केस में
आपको सिस्टम आइडियल प्रोसेस देखने को नहीं
मिलेगी कहने का मतलब होगी बट वो कंजन करते
नहीं देख जीरो मिलेगी क्यों दे इज वेरी लो
चांसेस यू फाइंड दिस प्रोसेस यह प्रोसेस
आपको मिलने के ही चांसेस बहुत कम है
क्योंकि एक बात बताइए मुझे अगर एक सर्वर
आप खरीदते हो लाखों करोड़ रुपए लगा के
क्या आप उसको आइडियल रखने के लिए खरीदोगे
आप य लोग बताइए क्या उसको आप एक आइडियल
मतलब खाली रखने के लिए खरीदोगे करोड़ रुपए
लगा दिए किसी चीज के ऊपर और आप बोल रहे हो
कि ठीक है मेरे को तो उसमें छोटा सा
एक वेब सर्वर रन करना है एक उसके अलावा
मुझे उसम कर कुछ काम ही नहीं करना तो क्या
इतने पैसे लगा के उसको आइडियल तो नहीं
छोड़ोगे
ना क्योंकि सर्वर पर पैसे आप तभी लगाओगे
जब आपको कुछ काम होगा ट इज वई वहां पर इस
प्रोसेस की जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि वहां पर
एक तो क्या होता है य वर्चुअल एजन
टेक्नोलॉजी का यूज करते हैं एक साथ
मल्टीपल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का यूज किया जाता
है तो सर्वर कभी भी फ्री नहीं रहता है
इसलिए वहां पर इस प्रोसेस की रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं है बहुत रेयर चांसेस है कि वहां पर
ये प्रोसेस आपको देखने को मिले दैट इज वई
आप जब भी इस टूल की हेल्प से देखोगे तो
आपको देखने को मिलेगी कि सिस्टम आइडियल
नाम की एक प्रोसे सेम ये ऐसा नहीं कि मैं
कोई पुराना स्क्रीनशॉट है लेटेस्ट
स्क्रीनशॉट है विंडोज 10 का और यह जस्ट
कुछ वन वीक पहले का स्क्रीनशॉट है ये ऐसा
नहीं और रनिंग मशीन का स्क्रीनशॉट हैय ऐसे
ही आपकी मशीन में भी देखने को मिलेगा आप
भी देख सकते हो मैं बता दूंगा तो इसलिए यह
आपकी सिस्टम आइडियल प्रोसेस समझ में आ गी
सिस्टम आइडियल प्रोसेस क्यों होती है आपके
मशीन के अंदर यह आपको हमेशा देखने को
मिलेगी सिस्टम आइडियल प्रोसेस हमेशा दे
देखने को
मिलेगी एंटीवायरस भाई सिग्नेचर डिटेक्शन
प्लस में आपके एंटीवायरस एग्जीक्यूशन करता
है एंटीवायरस क्या करता है एंटीवायरस
सीपीयू के साथ साथ नहीं उसको भी टा जो
हार्ड डिस्क में आपकी जितने भी एप्लीकेशंस
पड़ी है उनके भी सिग्नेचर कन्वर्ट करके
चेक कर
अभी मेरी मशीन का एग्जांपल लीजिए मेरी
मशीन मल्टी कोर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है 32जीबी
रम आपको क्या लगता कि मेरी मशीन एट ए टाइम
वन तो एप्लीकेशन रन नहीं करेंगी ना वो एट
ए टाइम कितने थ्रेड रन कर रही होगी तो उस
केस में भी तो सोचिए ना मशीन टू मशीन आई
है नॉर्मल टू नॉर्मल 16 जीबी रम यूज कर
रहे हैं लोग और मल्टीपल मशीन उसको यूज कर
रहे हैं
तो एंटीवायरस करता है ऐसा नहीं एंटीवायरस
उसी टाइम चेक कर लेता है और एंटीवायरस साथ
में आपकी
अगर मज क् ट्रैक्स की बात बताऊंगा अगर आप
मेमोरी एग्जीक्यूशन करते हो तो कम चांसेस
होते हैं एंटीवायरस के पास डिटेक्ट करने
के लेकिन व जैसे अपने डिस्क प इंस्टॉल कर
दिया तो एंटीवा डिटेक्ट कर लेता है और
आजकल बिहेवियर एनालिसिस के जो एंटीवायरस
है एडवांस एंटीवायरस है या आपके जो
सिक्योरिटी सोलूशंस है वो उसका बिहेवियर
एनालाइज करते
हैं ओके
समझ नहीं पाया सर्वर में यह प्रोसेस होती
है नहीं होती ही नहीं है तो कभी भी दूसरी
प्रोसेस बंद हो तो क्या होगा सर्वर किसलिए
एक चीज बताइए यार मेरे को एक छोटा सा सवाल
है कि सर्वर आपने लगाया तो सर्वर को आप कब
ऑफ करते हो सर्वर कभी ऑफ र
मेंटेनेंस टाइम में सर्वर की कुछ प्रॉब्लम
आ गई तो उसका बैकअप सर्वर रन करते हैं बट
किसी सर्वर को कभी आइडियल छोड़ा ही नहीं
जाता नहीं कभी भी किसी भी सर्वर को आइडियल
नहीं छोड़ा जाता आप वेब सर्वर की बात
कीजिए मैंने एक वेबसाइट बनाई है एक वेब
सर्वर लंच कर दिया तो अभी एक बात बताइए कि
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल तो पब्लिक कब छोड़ती है
कैसा थोड़ ना कि आप 10 बजे सो जाते हो
लेकिन पूरी दुनिया तो 10 बजे नहीं सोती ना
तो कभी भी आइडियल नहीं रहते
सर्वर्स तो नेक्स्ट चले नेक्स्ट
इंपोर्टेंट एक और प्रोसेस
है अगर आपका डाउट क्लियर हो गया हो
तो अगर आपका डाउट क्लियर हो गया तो आगे
चले
ओके नेक्स्ट एक प्रोसेस आपने देखी होगी
सिस्टम आइडियल प्रोसेस के नीचे सिस्टम
प्रोसेस एक्चुअल में य एक प्रोसेस नहीं है
इट इज अ टेक्निक टू सी दी कर्नल
यूटिलाइजेशन बिकॉज सम टाइम्स वन वी आर
ट्रबल शूटिंग ए प्रॉब्लम वी फाइंड ट
प्रोसेस इज ऑफ कर्नल ओके कई बार क्या होता
है कि पहली बात तोय कोई प्रोसेस नहीं है
यह एक तरीका है कर्नल यूटिलाइजेशन देखने
का आपको देखने को मिलेगा कई बार ऐसी
प्रॉब्लम आती है सिस्टम में जहां पर
सॉफ्टवेयर की या किसी प्रोसेस की प्रॉब्लम
नहीं होगी प्रॉब्लम क्या होगी सर्वर की
मतलब प्रोग्राम क्या होगी सॉरी कर्नल की
प्रॉब्लम होगी तो यह चीज देखने के लिए कि
मेरे कर्नल की प्रॉब्लम है यानी रेयरली
होता है प्रॉब्लम है या नहीं है तो उस चीज
उस केस में आप क्या करते इस प्रोसेस का
यूटिलाइजेशन देखते हो सम टाइम्स कनल इज
टेकिंग अ लॉट ऑफ सीपीयू टाइम्स अब कर्नल
हो सकता है कर्नल अकेला ले रहा है कर्नल
के अंदर क्याक है सर्विसेस हैं ड्राइवर्स
हैं एंड दैट आर इंटरेक्ट विद द कनल वह
सारे के सारे क्या करते हैं डायरेक्टली
कनल के साथ इंटरेक्ट करते हैं तो हो सकता
है वह उस टाइम को कंज्यूम कर रहे हो तो
मोर यूटिलाइजेशन मींस समथिंग इंपैक्टिंग द
कर्नल एंड दैट इज व्हाई कर्नल इज टेकिंग
सो मच टाइम अगर यहां का इसका यूटिलाइजेशन
आपको ज्यादा देखने को मिल रहा है सिस्टम
प्रोसेस का इसका मतलब क्या है कि आपका जो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है स्लो क्यों चल रहा है
क्योंकि कर्नल में कुछ प्रॉब्लम है कोई
ऐसा ड्राइवर्स है जो मिसबिहेव कर रहा है
या क्रैश हो गया है जो बार-बार अपने आप को
रिकवर करने की एग्रीड करने की कोशिश कर
रहा है जो सीपू क्योंकि ड्राइवर्स की और
जो सिस्टम सर्विसेस हैं जो इंपोर्टेंट
सिस्टम सर्विसेस जो डायरेक्टली कर्नल से
ट्रैक करती है उनकी प्रायोरिटी बाकी
नॉर्मल एप्लीकेशन की प्रायोरिटी से हाई
होती है इसलिए उनको ऑन प्रायोरिटी सीपीयू
टाइम मिलेगा तो इसलिए क्या बार-बार उनको
सीपीयू टाइम मिल रहा है और वो आपके पूरे
सीपीयू को कंज्यूम करके बैठे हुई है आपका
सीपीयू फ्री है ही नहीं जिसकी वजह से आपका
सीपीयू हैंग कर रहा है तो दैट इज द केस कई
बार ट्रबल शूटिंग में यह प्रोसेस यह जो
आपको प्रोसेस टाइप की दिख रही है यह
टेक्निक काम आ जाती है ट्रबल शूट करने के
लिए कि ओके ये प्रॉब्लम मेरे सॉफ्टवेयर की
नहीं है प्रॉब्लम मेरे हार्डवेयर साइड में
है किसी ड्राइवर की किसी सर्विस की कर्नल
साइड में ओके ये इसलिए एक सिस्टम नाम की
प्रोसेस भी आपको देखने को मिलती है
नेक्स्ट अगर मैं बात करूं इंटरप्ट्स आपने
देखा होगा ये इंटरप्ट नाम के ए मड आपको
पता है जब हम बूट अप करते हैं सबसे पहले
यूजर मोड में ऑपरेट करने वाली सर्विस होती
है प्रोसेस होती है ओके तो इंटरप्टस क्या
होता है दे आर आल्सो वेरी इंपोर्टेंट
हार्डवेयर नोटिफाई ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आई नीड
शेड्यूलर अब हार्डवेयर है वो भी ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम को य बोलते हैं कि मुझे भी
शेड्यूलर चाहिए मुझे भी शेड्यूल करो मुझे
भी सीपीयू टाइम चाहिए हार्डवेयर हैज द
एबिलिटी टू ओवरराइड लॉट ऑफ सॉफ्टवेयर इन
लिस्ट मैं आपको वही बताया कि हार्डवेयर के
पास क्या है कि हाई प्रायोरिटी है कि फॉर
एग्जांपल आपका माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड है आप
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड रन कर रहे हो लेकिन
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड में आप टाइपिंग करते हो
या माउस को यूज करते हो तो प्रायोरिटी
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट की ज्यादा है या हार्ड इसमें
आपके कीबोर्ड और माउस की प्रायोरिटी
ज्यादा होनी चाहिए किसकी प्रायोरिटी
ज्यादा होनी चाहिए
बताइए किसकी प्रायोरिटी हो ज्यादा होनी
चाहिए
हार्डवेयर की हार्डवेयर की प्रायोरिटी
ज्यादा होनी चाहिए आपके सीपीयू माउस की
प्रायोरिटी ज्यादा होनी चाहिए आपकी उस
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एप्लीकेशन की प्रायोरिटी
ज्यादा होनी चाहिए अगर माइक्रोसॉफ्ट यूज
कर रहे हो उसके ऊपर आपने टाइपिंग करना है
या कुछ क्लिक करना है कट कॉपी पेस्ट करना
है तो किसकी प्रायोरिटी ज्यादा होनी चाहिए
कीबोर्ड माउस की होनी चाहिए हार्डवेयर की
दैट इज वई हार्डवेयर की प्रायोरिटी ज्यादा
होती है किसी भी सॉफ्टवेयर से तो इसलिए
क्या करते हैं व ओवरराइड कर सकते हैं अब
यह क्यों दी गई है हियर इंटरप्ट इज एन
इंडिकेशन ऑफ हार्डवेयर ड्राइवर्स ये एक
इंडिकेशन है कि हार्ड इंडिकेशन ऑफ
हार्डवेयर ड्राइवर्स दे आर टेलिंग द
शेड्यूलर आई नीड अटेंशन एंड दिस इज वेरी
हेल्पफुल बिकॉज मेनी टाइम्स आवर
प्रॉब्लम्स आर ड्राइवर्स अगर हमारे
सिस्टम्स में ड्राइवर्स की प्रॉब्लम होगी
तो यहां पर जो इंटरप्टस है जो इंटरप्टस की
जो यूटिलाइजेशन होगा वो हाई मिलेगा और अगर
यहां पर इंटरप्टस के केस में आपको
यूटिलाइजेशन हाई मिल मिल रहा है इसका मतलब
आपकी स्पेसिफिकली किसी ड्राइवर की
प्रॉब्लम है जो बार-बार आपके सीपीयू का
टाइम कंज्यूम कर रहा रहा है जिसकी वजह से
भी आपका सिस्टम बहुत स्लो है समझ में आया
कि सिस्टम तो अभी सिस्टम ओनली यूटिलाइजेशन
हो रहा है तो यहां पर वी आर नॉट श्यर कि
कोई ड्राइवर है सर्विसेस है क्या है या
कर्नल में कोई प्रॉब्लम है ठीक है बट
कर्नल साइड प्रॉब्लम है अगर इंटरप्ट कंज
ओनली इंटरप्ट कंजन ज्यादा है कन
यूटिलाइजेशन तो होगा ही होगा प्लस में
इंटरप्ट कंजजशन ज्यादा है इसका मतलब क्या
है किय किसी स्पेसिफिक ड्राइवर की
प्रॉब्लम है जो बार-बार प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट
कर रहा है मेरा सीपीयू यूटिलाइजेशन ज्यादा
यूज कर रहा है जिसकी वजह से बाकी
एप्लीकेशंस को रन करने में प्रॉब्लम हो
रही है तो दज आर द थ्री इंपोर्टेंट
प्रोसेसेस या थ्री इंपोर्टेंट टर्म्स जो
मैं आपको बताने की कोशिश कर रहा था सबको
समझ में आई कि इंटरप्ट सिस्टम प्रोसेस और
सिस्टम आइडियल प्रोसेस क्यों होती है आपकी
सिस्टम में यहां से भी देख के आप
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
डाउट
है चलो मैं अभी स्क्रीन पर आ जाता हूं चलो
यस अगर किसी को कोई डाउट है मुझसे पूछ
सकते हैं आई विल आंसर आज का सेशन इतना ही
है आज के सेशन में यह बताए
किसको क्या समझ में नहीं
आया क्या सेशन अच्छा नहीं रहा या सेशन में
मजा नहीं आया
बताइए कोई भी कुछ डाउट पूछ सकता है
बताइए किसी का कोई डाउट है किसी का सवाल
है जो मुझसे पूछना चाहता है तो पूछ सकते
हैं कोई भी
क्या सेशन अच्छा नहीं था तो व भी बता
दीजिए क्या चेक करना
है मेरे सिस्टम में क्या चेक करना है एक
सॉफ्टवेयर होता मैं आपको बताता हूं देखो
एक
सिस्टम सिस
यह रहा एक यह पैकेट होता पूरा सिस
इंटर्नल्स का आप इसको डाउनलोड कर लो यह
रहा कभी भी इस चीज के लिए उसको डाउनलोड कर
लो यह रहा डाउनलोड प्रोसेस एक्सप्लोरर
नहीं ओनली पूरे उस पैकेट को डाउनलोड कर लो
प्रोसेस एक्सप्लोर इसका पार्ट है स इंटरनल
का मैं पूरे सूट को डाउनलोड कर रहा हूं
देखिए य नाउ नाउ वि दिस
वन डाउनलोड सीस इंटरनल यूटिलिटीज सस
इंटरनल सूट को मैंने क्या किया डाउनलोड कर
लिया कंपलीट सूट को मैं डाउनलोड कर सकता
हूं इसके अंदर बहुत सारी चीजें हैं इसके
अंदर बहुत कुछ देख सकते हो आप आपके सिस्टम
से रिलेटेड ट्रबल शूटिंग के टाइम में
ज्यादातर यूज किया जाता है इनका
ये रहा इसको एक काम करो
आप
एक्सक्लॉक ऑन दिस वन ना हो गया अभी दे लॉट
ऑफ टूल्स अभी मैं जो आपको देखना चाहता हूं
इसमें अभी मेरा है प्रोसेस
एक्सप्लोरर प्रोसेस एक्सप्लोरर में मेरा
कहां पर रखने का
मिलेगा इज माय प्रोसेस पीएस लॉग पीजी
पासवर्ड पीएस लिस्ट पीएस स्किल पीएस
एक्सपोस्ट पोस
सर्विसेस वन थिंग आई विल ट्राई
इट चेक करने दीजिए एक बार नो नो नो नो नो
नो नो एग्री नो नो दिस वन नॉट दिस वन
एक इसमें प्रोसेस एक्सप्लोरर होती है
यार प्रोसेस मॉनिटर प्रोसेस
मॉनिटर एंड दिस इज द फुल सूट एंड यह रहा
यह रहा प्रोसेस
एक्सप्लोरर प्रोसेस एक्सप्लो प्रोसेस
मॉनिटर मे बी दिस वन
अपडेट दिस वन नहीं दिस इ डिफरेंट यह अलग
है यह
रहा सेम यह
देखिए सिस्टम आइडियल
प्रोसेस सिप यूटिलाइजेशन सिस्टम प्रोसेस
इंटरप्टस एसडीसी उसके बाद
देखिए विन सर्विसेस एवीसी होस्ट क्या होती
है यह मैं बता दूंगा आपको देखिए दीज ऑल आर
द प्रोसेसेस यह इसका देखिए एक सिप
यूटिलाइजेशन मेमोरी यूटिलाइजेशन सब कुछ है
इसमें प्रोसेस आईडी
डिस्क्रिप्शन किसके द्वारा रन की गई है यह
सारी चीजें दज आर वेरी डिटेल टूल्स ओके तो
दिख गया सबको
हां प्रोसेस सेकर भी होता बहुत सारी चीजें
होते हैं यह बर बर के टूल्स य बहुत कुछ
देख सकते हो इसमें प्रोसेस मॉनिटर
रजिस्ट्री बहुत कुछ दे सकते हो मैं आगे
आगे दिखाऊंगा यूज करना भी ओके तो अभी आप
चाहो तो इसको इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो डाउनलोड
कर सकते हो मैं इसका लिंक प्रोवाइड कर
देता हूं आपको यह रहा कंट्रोल सी और
कंट्रोल व य रहा हिट
एंटर तो सबको सेशन क्लियर
है कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन हार्ड है नहीं ट्रबल
शूटिंग इंफॉर्मेशन
है आपके लिए इंफॉर्मेशन इसलिए जरूरी है जब
आप एक बार सिस्टम एक्सेस कर लिया तो आपको
फिर पता होना चाहिए ना कि कौन सी प्रोसेस
परमानेंट है कौन सी प्रोसेस परमानेंट नहीं
है कौन सी सर्विसेस हो सकती है कौन सी
क्या चीज हो सकती
है मानसिक नेट मोड लाइक ट योर प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क बेसिकली क्या है कि अपने वर्चुअल
बॉक्स में नेट अगर ऑन कर दिया तो आईपी
एड्रेस रेंज चेंज हो जाती है मतलब क्या कर
सकता है कि उनका खुद का एक लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क
है वो उनका खुद का लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क है
बाहर से जो आपकी होस्ट मशी व पिंग भी नहीं
कर सकती लेकिन ब्रिज मोड में क्या होता है
कि जिस नेटवर्क में आप ऑलरेडी हो ब्रिज
उसी नेटवर्क में ही आपने एक उसी लाइन के
अंदर पूरी सारी मशीन को कनेक्ट कर दिया
आपने फॉर एग्जांपल वीएम वेर है वर्चुअल
बॉक्स के अंदर तीन मशीन है आप चाहते हो कि
ये तीन मशीनों का एक आइसोलेट एनवायरमेंट
हो यह इससे बाहर कम्युनिकेट ना कर पाए
मतलब बाहर से कोई इसको पिंग ना कर पाए इन
मशीन को चेक ना कर पाए तो उस केस में आप
नेट का यूज करोगे तो आपकी कोई भी मशीन
उसको पिंग नहीं कर पाएगी ठीक है लेकिन आप
चाहते हो नहीं य तीनों मशीन मेरे इसी सेम
नेटवर्क में रहे जिसमें मेरी फिजिकल मशीन
है तो उस केस में आप ब्रिज मोड का यूज
करते
हो हा सुरत मुखर्जी अभी मैं लिनक्स की बात
नहीं कर रहा मैं विंडोज पढ़ा रहा हूं तो
मुझे यह चीज समझ में नहीं आती
आप नक् पढ़ते टाइम विंडोज पे फोकस करते हो
और विंडोज पढ़ते टाइम लिनेक्स पे फोकस
करते
हो बताइए और किसी का कोई सवाल जवाब मुझसे
पूछना चाहता है तो पूछ लीजिए अदर वाइज मैं
सेशन को एंड कर दूंगा
फिर मुझे सॉरी बोलने की जरूरत नहीं है
लेकिन आप खुद पूछ सोचिए कि
यार टॉपिक जब मैं पढ़ता हूं जिस चीज में
उसमें आउट ऑफ सिलेबस हम क्यों जाने की
कोशिश करते हैं इससे यह पता चलता है कि
मैं भी आपको एक चीज बताता हूं कि हमारा
इंटेंशन हमेशा रहता है कि चलो एक काम करते
हैं जो हमें पढ़ा रहा है ना उसका नॉलेज
चेक करते हैं किस लेवल त मैं बता सकता है
और किस लेवल तक नहीं बता सकता मतलब उसको
टाइट रखना है हमें इससे मतलब नहीं आज क्या
पढ़ा रहे हैं उस पर फोकस करने से मतलब
नहीं होता कुछ स्टूडेंट होते हैं जिनको
नहीं नहीं इंस्ट्रक्टर जो है बस आज उसको
थोड़ा टाइट करते हैं कुछ भी पूछ लेते हैं
ऐसा पूछेंगे कि हमारे सवाल का जवाब ना दे
पाए उसकी खुशी अलग ही होगी
ठीक है उसकी खुशी अलग ही होगी कि जैसे मैं
बताता हूं अपना एक किस्सा बताता हूं मैं
जब मैं आई वाज इन अराउंड ना
टू नहीं 12 टू 14 इयर्स एगो जब मैं आई एम
कंपलीटिंग माय 12थ जब मैं अपने 12
स्टैंडर्ड में था तो मैं क्या करता था कि
मैं भी तुम्हारी तरह ही था यार तुमसे अलग
तो थोड़ी ना था मैं तो अब मुझे पता कि आप
लोग क्या सोच सकते हो तो मेरे जो मैं
फिजिक्स जब पढ़ता था में एक फिजिक्स के
टीचर होते थे काफी मतलब लिटरली बहुत अच्छा
पढ़ाते थे तो जब मैं उनसे पढ़ता था तो व
क्या करते थे कि पढ़ता पढ़ता में क्या
करता एक बुक होती थी एच सी शर्मा की ठीक
है दे आर वेरी वेरी आईआईटी की बुक थी
आईआईटी लेवल की नॉलेज की और जहां पर
नॉर्मल फिजिक्स पढ़ने के बजाय मैं उस बुक
को लेकर बैठता और मैं मुझे और कुछ काम
नहीं मैं उसी दिन सिर्फ यही सोचता कि मैं
यह सोच के आता कि इसको ऐसा सवाल दूंगा मैं
कि वह आज सॉल्व ना कर पाए सबके इंटेंशन ये
रहता है आप लोगों का इंटेंशन वही रहता है
तो अब मैं डेफिनेटली देता था
और वो भी बहुत स्मार्ट होते थे वो कैसे ना
कैसे उन्होंने बुक पढ़ रखी थी वो आंसर दे
देते थे लेकिन एक दिन कभी महीने में दो
महीने में एक बार क्या हुआ था कि एक दिन
एक ऐसा सवाल मिला था जो उनको आंसर नहीं कर
पाए वो तीन दिन तक बोला या मैं बताता हूं
तो वही चीज है उस दिन मैं बहुत खुश और मैं
सब अपने फ्रेंड्स के साथ सबको ये बोलता कि
अरे यार मैंने नहीं आज फिजिक्स वाले सर को
नहीं मैंने वो कर दिया मैं सवाल का आंसर
नहीं कर पाए यह है वो है लाइक दैट सेम
आपकी तरह ही तो मुझे पता है कि आप लोग कि
आउट ऑफ सिलेबस क्यों जाते हो आप सामने
वाले टीचर्स की नॉलेज चेक करना चाहते हो
कि आज आपको अलग खुशी होती है उस चीज की क
यू आर ए स्टूडेंट और आपकी जो एज आपको
छोटी-छोटी खुशियों से मतलब होता है ना कि
और लेकिन मुझे बाद में रिलाइज हुआ कि जो
मैं गलती कर रहा था मेरी गलती वही थी कि
प्रेजेंट में रहकर जो टॉपिक है कांसेप्ट
खास काश उसमें और ज मैं डीप में जाके
पढ़ता या डीप में जाकर उनसे नॉलेज लेता या
उस पर फोकस करता तो उसके लिए मुझे
एक्स्ट्रा नहीं पढ़ना पड़ता तो उसकी सीख
यह है कि भाई जब प्रेजेंट में जो चीज चल
रही होती है उस चीज पर फोकस कीजिए उस चीज
के बारे में जानिए हा उससे रिलेटेड सवाल
पूछिए और जो समझना है आपको जो समझ में
नहीं आता व खुद की रिसर्च कीजिए यह आपकी
हेल्पफुल रहेगी लाइफ टाइम रदर देन कि आप
मेरे से ऐसा सोच रहे हो कि एक्सपेक्टेशन
रख रहे हो कि हम ऐसा सवाल पूछते हैं सरसे
आज फसा लेते हैं नॉट पॉसिबल आप मुझे नहीं
फसा
पाओगे क्योंकि अगर मुझे नहीं भी पता होगा
लिटरली बोल रहा हूं मेरे पास इतने सिस्टम
है दे आर थ्री सिस्टम्स किसी एक पर चट
जीपीटी कर लूंगा और मुझे अगर किसी चीज का
नहीं पता होगा फॉर एग्जांपल बिल्कुल ही
ब्रांड नहीं होगी आपका जो सवाल होगा
टिपिकली इट्स ओके चट जीबी से पूछूंगा वो
कुछ ऐसे शब्द मेरे सामने प्रेजेंट कर देगी
जिनका मुझे मतलब पता है और तो मैं आसानी
से आपके सवाल का जवाब दे सकता
हूं बस इट इज वेरी इजी फॉर मी तो तो आप
ऐसा करने के बजाय एक काम कीजिए ना खुद से
कीजिए वो चीज मेहनत कीजिए प्रेजेंट के साथ
चलिए मेरे को फसा के आपको कुछ नहीं मिलने
वाला मैं फसू नहीं आपसे डोंट
ट्राइट तो और किसी का कोई
सवाल
बताइए किसी और कोई सवाल है या
कुछ प्रैक्टिकल लैब किस चीज की चाहिए
बताइए
प्रैक्टिकल लैब इनकी प्रैक्टिकल लैब बता
दिया आपको टूल मैंने आपको बताया यार उसको
मॉनिटर कर सकते हो इसकी प्रैक्टिकल लब
क्या करेंगे मैं प्रोसेस क्रिएट करके
दिखाऊ लेकिन पन टेस्टिंग करेंगे तो य सारी
प्रैक्टिकल्स में आएंगी आपको पता रहेगा कि
मैं किस एप्लीकेशन को कब यूज कर रहा हूं
तो प्रैक्टिकल्स रहेंगे डोंट वरी अभी एक ब
फंडामेंटल समझिए मेरे साथ चलिए मैं आपको
कभी भी गलत रास्ते पर नहीं लेकर जाऊंगा
फ्री में हूं पैसे नहीं ले रहा तो इसका
मतलब भी नहीं कि आप लोगों को मैं गलत
रास्ते लेकर
जाऊंगा मेरी जो ड्यूटी है मेरी जो
जिम्मेदारी
है मुझे अच्छे से पता है आप लोगों को कभी
भी अगर
मुझे ऐसा लगेगा कि मैं तुम्हें गलत रास्ते
पर लेकर जाऊ उसी दिन क्लास बंद कर दूंगा
तो मैं गलत रास्ते पर तुम्हारा टाइम वेस्ट
नहीं करूंगा इतना याद खना कि कभी जिंदगी
में तुम्हारा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करूंगा जो
चीज सिखाऊंगा रोड मैप के हिसाब से
तुम्हारे हिसाब से सिखाऊंगा लेकिन तुम्हें
कभी गलत गाइड नहीं करूंगा नहीं पता होगा
नहीं पढ़ाऊंगा
हो सकता कहीं पर क्लास मुझे छोड़ दूंगा
इट्स ओके कोई दिक्कत नहीं बट तुम्हारा
टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करूंगा आई नो कि
स्टूडेंट्स का टाइम बहुत कीमती होता है
बहुत मुश्किल से टाइम मिलता है जो सिंसियर
स्टूडेंट बहुत मुश्किल से टाइम मैनेज करते
हैं चीजों के लिए मुझे पता है तुम्हारा
टाइम मैं कभी खराब नहीं करूंगा तो इस पे
इतना विश्वास कर सकते हो जो चीज पढ़ाऊंगा
गलत नहीं पढ़ाऊंगा
कभी गलत हो जाती तो मुझे टोक दिया करो सर
यह नहीं शायद आप गलत पढ़ा रहे हो शायद यह
ऐसा हो सकता प्लीज क्रॉस चेक
कीजिए तो आई विल डेफिनेटली क्रॉस चेक एंड
अगेन आंसर
यू सम टाइम्स टीचर्स भी गलत हो सकता है
यार ज नहीं कि उसको हर चीज पता
हो कोई बार आपको मुझसे ज्यादा पता हो समझ
रहे हो तो बिल्कुल मत सोच करो कि गलत
पढ़ाएंगे कि पेन टेस्टिंग के नाम पर यह
प्रोसेस क्यासे काम करती है ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम कैसे काम करता है क्यों मुझे इससे
कोई मतलब नहीं क्यों पढ़ रहे हो तो ट्रस्ट
मी आज काम नहीं आएगी लेकिन कब काम आएगा
कभी एक दिन हम डिस्कस करेंगे ना कि
प्रॉब्लम्स क्या है आपको जॉब ना मिलने की
प्रॉब्लम्स क्या है आपके जब मैं पर्सनल
आपकी बातें करूंगा ना आपसे पर्सनल दिल की
बातें लूंगा डेफिनेटली लूंगा जल्दी लूंगा
तो फिर आपको खुद रिलाइज होगा
सीच का ऑफिशियल एग्जाम का अगर आपको सीच
थ्योरी देना है तो यूडी मी पर जाइए और
बोलो कि सीच प्रैक्टिस एग्जाम वहां पर मिल
जाएंगे छछ 12 12 सेट मिल जाएंगे वहां से
प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो ओनली थ्योरी एग्जाम
का आपको अगर देना ही है बट मेरे भाई मत
दीजिए इससे अच्छा जीजी पीटी दे लीजिए दे
आर बेटर
देन 00 लगाओगे उसके एग्जाम के लिए कुछ
फायदा नहीं है इससे बढ़िया ईजी पीटी दो
प्रैक्टिकल नॉलेज तो
मिलेगी ओके तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं
ज्यादा आपका टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करूंगा शायद
आपका कोई सवाल नहीं है और पर्सनल सवालों
के लिए एक दिन मैं स्पेशली सेशन रखूंगा
मीट अप लाइक दैट कि आप लोग कुछ भी सवाल
पूछ सकते हो आपकी मैं पर्सनल जो सबके तो
नहीं कर पाऊंगा जितने रेगुलर स्टूडेंट
उनके आंसर करने की कोशिश करूंगा मैं ओके
तो आज को को एंड करें फिर
बताइए और नेक्स्ट सेशन कंटिन्यू चलेगा और
आने वाले सेशन में आपको बता देता हूं कि
कैसे कैसी चीजें आने वाली हैं इसके बाद
कंटिन्यू चलेगा देन हम डीएलएल भी पढ़ेंगे
सर्विसेस में डीप जाके पढ़ेंगे और उसके
बाद रजिस्ट्री के बारे में भी पढ़ेंगे हम
और भी बहुत कुछ इसका नेटवर्किंग कैसे काम
करती है और भी एक दो चीजें और जो आपकी पन
टेस्टिंग के लिए जरूरी है तो एटलीस्ट पांच
से छह तो क्लास मान के चलिए फंडामेंटल्स
की उसके उसके बाद हम इसकी कुछ बेसिक कमांड
लाइन प्रैक्टिस करेंगे कि जो कमांड सीएमडी
के अंदर की जो हमें कमांड पता होनी चाहिए
ए पेन टेस्टर देन उसके बाद फिर हम पेन
टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट करेंगे विंडोज की ओके
दिस इज माय अप्रोच तो आइए जवाइन कीजिए और
सीखिए और अपने पैसे वेस्ट होने से
बचाइए तो ओके तो बाय बाय टेक केयर एंड सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेक्शन हम अगले सेशन में
मिलते हैं जल्दी बाय बाय गुड नाइट